You're about to learn the Python
programming language from scratch,
you'll learn everything from setting
up your system to program with Python
to working with API's, Bobby Stearman
from dig coding teaches this course.
Hi, everyone. I'm Bobby stemming from decoding.
And this is my Python course for beginners. So
if you're looking to learn Python, or polish up
on some skills you've already got, then you are
in the right place. Because in this course, we'll
be covering topics such as setting up our system
to use Python, we'll be looking at numbers,
strings, data types, control flows, classes,
and all the fundamental things that sit in
between. And before we close off the course, we'll
then use those newfound Python skills to write
some Python programs. But before we jump into it,
I just like to say a big thank you to the guys at
Freako camp for publishing this course, you guys
are fantastic, you're doing an outstanding
job, keep up the good work, and also keep
that content coming that is absolutely free. So
without further ado, let's jump straight into it.
So you can see here that I'm on pythons main
website, this is python.org. So this course has
been designed around their own documentation. I've
extrapolated out the parts that I feel are the
fundamentals for you as a beginner. But we will
be becoming familiar with their site because like
I say, I've referenced the documentation quite
a lot. So if you visit python.org, hover over
downloads on the nav bar, you can see here, it's
given me the option to download three, point 10.2.
That's the latest and greatest stable version of
Python as of the time of recording this video. So
if I click that, that will download an installer,
minus download. And it will say that as you become
better at Python, and you become a freelance or
a software engineer, then you will start working
on projects that may have been built some time
ago, in which case, you may need an older version
of Python on your machine. To do that, hover over
your machine, type on the left hand side and click
that will take you through to a different page
and you have all of the different releases
that you can download. So for instance, if I
wanted to download 3.9 point 10, I could click
this here and it would download the installer and
I can go about and just install it in the same way
as we are now about to for three point 10.2. It's
a little bit more advanced than beginner, but I
thought it'd be worthwhile just noting it down.
So the installer is hit and ready to open up.
Okay, so it's given me the option. Let me just
zoom in a little bit that you can see that a
little bit better. So it's giving me the option
to install now. Now you can click that and it will
go ahead and he'll install Python in that path.
I don't find it very intuitive. I like to keep
Python in my own path of choice, because if I
want to download more versions, I know exactly
where they are. And I can just flick between
them as when necessary. So we're going to go
with custom install. And we're also going to
click the Add python three point center path.
Because if you're using let's say a web framework,
such as Django, Django, we need to look in your
environment variables in your path to understand
where Python is on your machine. So it's important
we click that OK, zoom out quick. So we will click
that, click on Customize. And you can see a whole
bunch of things ticked, just keep them ticked.
Okay, this is the first install that you've
done. So let's get the documentation that's get
a package manager called PIP. We'll be using that
later on in the course. So keep that ticked.
Okay, and keep everything else ticked for now.
Click Next. And then we've got zoom in
again, we've got a few other options here,
just keep it as as you can see that the fourth
one down, says as Python, add python two
environment variables, that is important, we'll
do that. Okay. So all we need to do is click on
Browse and change the customized install location.
So I'll go ahead and do that. And I like to keep
my Python versions in my PC, C drive. And in
here, I'll create a directory called Python.
session which contained by Okay, we got one
cool place and have we we have Okay, great.
We will then go in there and create a new
folder. And we'll call this Python. We tend to
click enter. So if I was to install Python
397, I'll create a file called Three point 9.7.
And I'll install all of the Python packages
and files and configurations in that directory.
So it keeps it all in his own little container
so you can keep flicking between them. Okay,
that's why I do it that way. So we click that,
click OK. You can see now where it says customize
install location is now changed to Python, Python
3102. Okay, now we want to click Install. There
we go. It shouldn't take more than a few seconds,
but that's now going ahead and it's fetching and
installing all of the Python bits and bobs and
adding it to the directory that we just created.
And to test to make sure that it is on our machine
present correct and working as expected, we need
now need to fire up what's called a command prompt
on Windows. Now it's called a terminal on Mac.
But you, you fire it up on Windows by
going to the search bar and just type in
CLM, it'll come up with command prompt. Mine looks
a little bit different to what yours would because
I've changed the settings, yours will probably
be black. But all you need to do is type Python,
put python three or three point 10. If you're
on Mac or Unix, you put dash dash version.
Okay, actually, because we've got the pi
dot exe file installed from this install,
we can actually reference on a Windows
machine machine, Python with pi.
And that should still give us python three, point
10.2. You can see that there you go. Happy Day. So
we've now installed Python on our machine, we're
now ready to start looking at the interpreter,
which will then start looking at things like
text editors and IDs and things like that.
So let's call it a day with this video.
And I'll be seeing you in the next video.
So I'm on a Windows machine. So I'm using
a command prompt. So if you are on a UNIX,
Mac or Linux, then he is a different
command to me when firing up the
interpreter or using just general Python
commands, you'd use python three point 10.
Now I use Python or p y. The reason I know I use
the command p y is because this paragraph here,
I installed p y dot exe launcher in the last video
I put together which we use to install Python on
our machine. So when I'm on my command prompt, and
I'm typing things such as p y dash dash version,
you would put python three point 10 dash dash
version to do exactly the same thing. Oh,
typo there, but you see what I'm saying? Okay,
so let's fire up the interpreter with p y.
This autonomy, the interpreter is open.
And in interactive mode. That's what these
three great n symbols are telling me. So give
me some code, I want to do something with it.
But before I type into it, this understand
what the interpreter is doing. So as I
typed Python code into this interpreter, it's
translating it into a universal language Binary.
Binary is ones and zeros. Yeah. And like this.
difficult to read, you can understand this is
the programming language that software engineers
used to use back in the day when writing programs
1000s and 1000s and 1000s of lines, ones
and zeros. Joe Average could not just sit
on a seat and start coding, it's a pain in the
ass. Okay, so and it wasn't very scalable. So
from binary, the assembly language was put
together and this kind of streamlined binary, it
allowed you to use much more easier to understand
commands to do the same thing. But assembly
languages weren't transferable between machines.
So my Windows assembly language didn't work
on a different operating system. Okay, so then
high level languages were designed, okay. And this
took the assembly language to the next level. This
allows programmers to write code in a humanized
way in an elegant way to a cent and then translate
it to binary. Okay, so that's what so these high
level languages, PHP, C++, you've got Java. And of
course, you got Python, right. So these languages
allow us to code in an elegant way, and then
things like the interpreter, but then translate
that into binary code. So our machines know what
you're trying to do. Now, I hope it didn't just
butcher the explanation. But I've just tried to
break down what the interpreter actually doing.
Because when I started, I didn't get explanation,
I just wondered what the hell I was doing, I just
start typing away and it magically done something
in the background. So I hope now you understand
what it is and how it works. But before I close
this video off this just buyer in some code,
and just see it working, so I can just put a
simple one plus one, so integer plus integer,
in this case, one plus one, if I press Enter, it
will then run that command. And the result is two.
So we can go 10 multiplied by six, or we can use
the multiplication operator, which in this case
is a star, press enter, and it spits out 60. So
that is the interpreter, okay. All it's doing is
taken our code, in this case Python, and it's
just translating it so that your machine can do
something with it. Okay, so let's close this
video off. In the next video, we will start
looking at text editors and it is so thanks for
watching. I'll see you in the next video. Bye bye
Okay, so my browser is open on microsoft.com on
our Visual Studio Code page, because we will be
installed in VS code. In today's video vs. Code
is a text editor. Now we use text editors. Because
in the interpreter, we can easily write
single lines of code. We can run scripts,
but it doesn't really help us with things like
syntax, errors and debugging. That's where text
editors come into it. And also, they will help us
as a developer manage things like directory trees
and the hundreds of files. Okay, that's why we use
text editors, there are apps that we can install
that help us just do our day to day job. Now, IDE,
which are integrated development environments,
take text editors to the next level, they
do everything that a text editor can do. But
with all the bells and whistles, so they help you
with things like debugging, and deployment. Okay,
I will be installing a text editor called VS
code because it behaves like an IDE because it
has been called extensions. And it's fantastic.
And in fact, the reason I'm installing VS code is
because on their own website, they've got a tool
here, that helps you decide what's best for you,
based on what you do. Okay, so under the
languages, platforms and workflows, you can click,
so you can click the machine you're using,
then the languages, platforms and workflows,
you can click, in my case, desktop, Python,
JavaScript. And it's telling me that the right
job for what I do or sorry, the right app for my
job is download Visual Studio code. So let's go
ahead and do that. It will download the installer,
redirect us First, download an installer.
And then if we open that, I'll open up the
installer, I will zoom in because it's quite small
on my screen here. Okay, so it's asking us to read
the T's and C's, please do that. It's always worth
doing that I've already read them. So I'm going
to go ahead and click the I accept the agreement.
Click Next. It will then ask you where you want
VS code to be saved, I'm going to go ahead and
just keep it with the default, it then asks you
to was this select Start menu folder, just keep
that as next it's fine, then it's giving you some
extra options. One of them is quite important is
telling you to add it to your path. So same as
installing Python, let's get this added to our
PATH environment variable so that it's accessible,
and we know exactly where it is on our machine.
And then if we click next, it will summarize
and we can then click Install should only take a
minute or two. But it's now installing all of the
files and all of the configurations in the path
that it suggested. When it's done, it asks us if
we want to launch VS code, we will keep that text
and click Finish. And in a future video, I'll show
you how to open VS code in a certain directory as
and when necessary. So I already had an instance
VS code on my machine, and it's opened up in the
directory, which is going to be the cheat sheet
for this course. And you can see that it's got
all of the different topics that we'll be going
through. But this is VS code, okay. So if I just
zoom in a little bit, there we go, we've got an
explorer, here, we don't necessarily need to open,
it doesn't really matter. So we've got an
explorer, tab or panel, we've got a panel
here that we can actually write straight into.
So if I open up a new file here, and just put
hello with an extension P why, because
it's a python file that I'll open this up,
and I can write straight into it. Okay, but what
is beautiful about VS code is we can install a an
extension that will help us with syntax errors,
click Extensions on the left type in Python,
that'll give you a whole bunch of Python
extensions. Now I've got this one installed.
It's called Python. And it's been installed
by over 50 million people actually,
I looked at this the other day, and it was 49
and a half million. So there's a lot of people
installing this extension. So not that, you got
to assume that 50 million people can't be wrong,
right. So it's good, it's gonna help you with
syntax errors, get it installed, or select
another one and get that installed on your VS
code instance. And it will help you with syntax.
Let's go back into the panel here. And also was
good about VS code is got a terminal built in.
So where I've got my command prompt here, let
me close that down, I will open up a terminal.
Mine defaults to CMD. Because I've changed the
settings, yours might be PowerShell. But you can
select the type with this pulldown list, click
Command Prompt. And then you can simply put p y,
happy days. Now I can type straight into here, one
plus one. And you can see that that works. And you
can see here that actually this is what is under
underlined squiggle here or underlined squiggle.
It's telling me that actually that's a syntax
error, and that's coming up as a problem and is
explaining it here. That's because we've got the
extension installed. So that is done right Got
a text editor installed on our machine, we've got
VS code installed, we've got a text editor, we now
can start coding in Python. In fact,
whilst I've got this directory open,
you can see that we're going to start going
through these files and talking about each of
the topics in detail using VS code. So that
marks the end of this video. Thank you very
much for watching. In the next video, we will
install Git Bash. And the reason we'll install
Git Bash is because this repository is on GitHub,
and you need to clone it down to get access to it
on your machine. So thanks for watching.
I'll see you in the next video. Bye bye.
So Git is a version control system.
And with Git installed in your machine,
you can manage version control using places
such as GitHub, GitLab, and BitBucket. Okay,
so it's important you got git on your machine,
I have already got 2.3 5.1 on my machine,
which is the latest and greatest version at the
point of recording. So I won't be following along
with this video because it gets a bit clunky,
and it switches my video off and it's just not
pretty when you're trying to watch and follow
along. So I'll show you the steps get installed,
get get installed in your machine and come back
to the video. Okay, so click the link here. Oh,
sorry, right, we are on get dash scm.com.
Okay, that's where you will find get.
And you need to click on a version of when get
for your machine type miners window. So click
on download for Windows, when you get redirected,
click on the link that is the right one for your
machine. Mine's a 64 bit Windows, so I need the
installer. For that, I would click this here. And
that will download the installer. When downloaded,
open up the installer and follow along with the
easy step by step guide. And that will get gets
on your machine. Okay, so now that you've got
get this open up VS code in the correct directory,
or in your directory that you want this to be,
I want mine to be in my course directory,
click here. This is an easy way of opening
an instance of VS code without opening
and then scrolling and trying to navigate,
type CMD. When your command prompt opens, just put
code space period and that will open an instance
of VS code in your development directory. So
now we need to clone down so open a terminal
from a drop down, open up Git
Bash. Now you'll only have this
option if you've got git on your machine. So
that's why it's important. You've got Git. Okay,
so now we want to use the command git clone. And
then after that, we need to dump in there the URL
of the repository. So in GitHub, the
repository that you want to look for
is github.com/bobby-d, coding slash Python course
for beginners, this is a public repository,
and all of the documentation is in there. Okay,
so we've got all of these different Python files.
So click code and the main branch and
copied this code here, open up VS code,
dump it in there, space, full stop, and
that will clone down a repository into
your directory. It's asking me for a
passcode. Because I've got an S H. SSH key.
There we have it. Okay, so you probably won't get
asked for a passphrase. And no bother. So this is
the supporting documentation. So there's open up
one of the first ones we'll be looking at numbers.
So numbers dot p y, this is the first thing
we'll be looking at. These other supporting
documentation, use these as cheat sheets. So at
the end of this course, you can always refer back
to these files, make your own notes, it's really,
really helpful. I do use cheap seats, there are
some certain things that I might not necessarily
use on a daily or weekly basis, I just need a
refresher. So that would be my advice, save these
on your machine and keep referring back to them.
So that is the end of this video. Hopefully now
we'll be ready to start really jumping into this
course, and start looking at Python code itself.
And we'll be signed with numbers. So thanks for
watching. I've enjoyed making this video. I'll
see you in the next video. Thank you bye bye
so I've got VS code opened up on my screen here
in the file called numbers dot p y. There are a
few of these files in the supporting documentation
that we cloned down from GitHub in the last video,
but we're looking at numbers. So we're close
the Explorer because I want to use as much
real estate as possible. You see here I've got
a terminal with the interpreter up and running.
Okay, that's what these great symbols
mean. You do that simply by if we put exit
Hello myself though a little bit in their
terminal or command prompt, just put p y,
if you're on Windows, and there you
go, there's the interpreter. But we'll
be using the interpreter to take an input and
return an output. So the input will be a sum,
the output will be the result. That's what we're
doing. We're using it as a calculator. In Python,
we have a whole bunch of operators that we can
tap into. Let's make a bit bigger. We've got
the symbols, that's the operator and what it
does the description here, okay, so we've got
pluses addition, subtraction, multiplication,
nice and easy, right basic stuff, division.
Now that will always return a float, which is a
number type, we'll talk about that in a second. So
10 divided by four be 2.5. Floor division
is the same but returns the integer version,
so four divided, so 10 divided by four would be
two, so 2.5, remove the decimal and a five is two.
So less floor division modulus is the remainder
of 10 divided by four, which would be two, so
that's the remainder. So four goes into 10 twice,
the remainder is two, so four plus four is eight.
The remainder is two, as modulus, then you've
got power of so star star is if you put a five
star star two would be five to the power
of two. So five, times five, five star star
three would be five times five times five,
which would be one to five. That's power of
you've then got assignment operators got equals,
okay, yeah, there are other ones we've got equals
equals got equals great and, and so on and so
forth. Now, if you go to pythons doc page, if you
look up here, we've got Doc's dot org slash three
slash tutorial slash introduction to HTML, that
is pythons documentation, to an introduction
to numbers. I've extrapolated everything I
feel is basic stuff, you can do a deeper dive
on their docks, please feel free. This course
has been designed around that documentation. So
I wanted to give you the very, very basics, okay.
Okay, so got number types. But integers, we've
got floats, integers are whole numbers. Floats are
numbers with decimal places. Okay, you've then got
fractions. But again, this is a beginners class.
Okay, so look at INTZ and floats. Today, you got
some built in functions we're using round today.
So if we were to use round
function on this number here,
you could pass through a number and then
pass through the amount of decimal places
you want. And it will, it would return the rounded
version. So for instance, if I pass 5.6667 data,
there are three to this function here, as the
number change decimals to two, that would return
5.67. Okay, we use in dev mode, we're also going
to use what else power. So these are a couple of
other functions that we've got here that are
built in to numbers, really, really helpful.
dev mode returns a tuple of the result of the
floor division, and modulus. So dev mod 10,
four would return to two. We'll look at that in
a second. Lastly, before we jump into actually
throwing in inputs and getting outputs, Python is
a really handy way of representing large integers.
So 4 billion, which looks a bit hard to read, can
be represented as this for underscore three zeros,
underscore three zeros underscore three zeros,
I think is a really handy way of representing
large numbers, especially if your code in so
Okay, let's look at some of these basics here.
And we will dump them straight into the
interpreter. So anything that comes after a hash
is a comment and the interpreter knows to ignore
it. Okay, the comment is for you. Excuse me. So
two plus two simple addition is four, five minus
two is three, seven times 10 is 70. Simple stuff,
right? All we're using is the interpreter as a
calculator, then you got division, so 10 over
four would be 2.5. Okay, which is a float 2.5 flow
mod is the same calculation, but rather than 2.5,
it would be two because it would disregard the
decimal place and 510. Modulus four would be two.
Okay, and then div mod would be two and two.
Because it's this sum, this sum of 10 and four,
they show you what I mean. Go in here,
right click, press enter. Fine. Now.
It's a bit hard when you zoom so far in
when you're doing a screen share too.
Show you what we're doing here, right so
10 over four is 2.5 10 divided by four
2.5 10 floor division over four so 10 With flow
division four, b two, because rather than 2.5,
you're removing the point five, that leaves to
10. Modulus four is four goes into 10, twice,
whole, okay? That gives you eight
and the remainder of that sum is two.
That's why it's two in dev mode, which is a built
in function is doing floor division, and then
modulus. So 10, we possibly 1014 is essentially
doing two calculations, two, and two. Brilliant.
Again, you can spend as much time as you
like adding these into your own interpreter,
you can always add other sums to give you a
much better rounded knowledge of numbers in
your own time. But there's a kind of a simple
walkthrough for you as a beginner. Okay,
I now copy this, these are fancy some, so think
of BOD mass when you're looking at these sums.
So brackets are the division, multiplication,
addition, subtraction in that order.
And what will happen is, oh, let's copy
this copy, there we go. So it will do this
part first, because that is the multiplication.
So five times six is 3050 minus 30, is 20.
It will do this first because the brackets, and
I will do this inside the brackets first, because
there's multiplication. So it's 50 minus 30, is
2020 divided by four is five, which is division,
so it would turn a float, then you got five
times three plus two, so 15 plus 270. Okay.
I say five fancy, some sums can get a lot more
fancy than that, then you have five power of two,
which would be 25. And I did say earlier, five,
multiple power of three would be one to five,
which is correct. So two to the power of
seven is one to eight, if I remember rightly,
that was more than that, oh is one to eight. But
you can also use a built in function called pal,
which saves the use of the star star,
I don't know what's easier to read,
but two to the power of seven,
returns the same as one to eight,
then variables. So it's not really numbers, but
you can assign anything to a variable. And today,
we were assigning numbers to one. So 60 is
assigned to the variable width, we're using
that assignment operator, height equals 21,
three times seven. So width multiplied by height,
I think is 12801260. There you go. I was tinkering
with this earlier. So rather than doing 60,
times by three times seven,
which is essentially the sum,
you're assigning the numbers to a variable, and
you're using the variables to do the sum itself.
Okay, which is all fun. And lastly, before
I close off this video, let's look at this.
So in interactive mode in the interpreter, the
last printed expression, which is really handy,
gets saved to an automatically saved to a
variable underscore, so you don't need to assign
it at all it knows to assign it to an underscore
variable. So we bought this into the interpreter.
Okay, price times tax has now automatically
been assigned to underscore, okay.
So if I can, if I now do price plus underscore
hope it's just type it in RBZ. There you go.
So price plus underscore is one, one 3.0 65.
Now that expression has been saved to the
variable underscore, so you see how they've
gone underscores and consistent every expression
on the last one is assigned to it. Okay.
Now, if I use round, it's not liking it. So I
type it, round, underscore, comma to remember
that function we looked at earlier. There we go.
Round underscore, underscore is one one 3.0 65
decimal places to says One, one 3.06. Okay, so
this is my whistlestop tour of numbers. Okay,
there's a lot more to learn. There's fractions.
There's all of the different operators,
you can do really, really fancy sums using
numbers. Please look at the documentation on
Python. There's no better place to learn numbers
than Python numbers page. There's like I say this
is just all for beginners. So keep the supporting
documentation add more notes as you find something
else that is interesting. But that is the
end of this video. Thanks for watching, have
enjoyed making it and I'll see you in the next
video which will all be about strings. Bye bye.
So again, I've got a VS code instance open on my
screen here in settings dot p y, which is one of
the files we downloaded or cloned from GitHub. We
look in the Explorer here. You can see there's a
whole bunch of other files, but we're looking at
strings today. So Python can be used to manipulate
strings, which can be expressed in a few different
ways. They can be enclosed in single quotes or
double quotes. So it doesn't matter, it is still
a string, if expressed in one or the other way.
Now, a backslash is used to escape out
of a string, or a quote should I say,
and that's really helpful. And one of the
examples that I've got in a moment or two,
because there's certain words that use this A and
apostrophe, and if you're using single quotes,
then you can imagine that you're in a whole spot
of bother with that string unless you escape out.
Okay? So Python strings cannot be
changed, they aren't immutable. So
you cannot isolate a character in a string
and replace it with something else. Okay,
you have to create a new string
altogether, which is completely possible,
we'll be looking at a built in function called
Len in this video. Now Lenny's really helpful,
you can use it on strings, lists, dictionaries,
tuple sets, and it returns the number of items
or characters in any one of those objects.
Really helpful with strings. So if we called Len
on my name, which is Bobby, it will return five
because Bobby has got five characters in it.
Okay? strings have a whole bunch of methods.
Now these are really, really helpful. Okay,
so I've listed out all of the different
methods that you can use on a string.
So for instance, capitalized there, you've got a
bit of space. So if I put bA, bB y as a string,
capitalize would return Bobby, okay, as a string,
really helpful method to use. And you've got a
whole bunch of other stuff here as well, you've
got case fold sent accounting code. Where else
other examples so that he got right at the
bottom that you got apart. So that would just be
Bobby would return. Bobby is all uppercase, okay.
So really helpful methods when managing strings,
you'll be using them a lot. Okay, you now need to
open up a terminal and open up a interpreter. So I
mean windows at p y. I've got my three Greatland
symbols there. So it's ready for an input.
So I've got a few examples here that if I bought
them straight into the interpreter, we can see
what's actually going on here. Okay, so the top
here, we've got sperm and eggs in single quotes,
as an input, so the output is a string, span x
doesn't has an apostrophe, okay, so single quotes,
single quotes, because we need to use a single
quote in the string, you need to escape out using
backslash, and it converts the single quotes or
double quotes, and then you return your output
is doesn't have double quotes, really helpful
understanding the backslash. Or you could just
write that string as double quotes, and you won't
have any problem whatsoever. Now in this example,
we've got double quotes in the string itself
that haven't been escaped out. So of course,
what gets returned is that whole string, the
double quotes within the string are characters.
way you can escape out and use the double quotes.
In the string itself, sorry, would be
to use the escape and it changed the
double quotes to single quotes. That is pretty
much the polar opposite of the dozen example.
So if we had single quotes, we use an apostrophe
in that example, we use in double quotes. And
actually, we want to use double quotes in the
string. And in which case, you need the escape,
backslash, okay. If you look at the documentation
on Python, if you look in 3.1, point two, on
docs.python.org/three/tutorial/introduction,
that is their intro to strings, do a deeper
dive in there, I've extrapolated out a whole
bunch of stuff. Hopefully, that is just the
basics that I've got in my video here. Okay,
so next, we've got new lines. So new line is
represented in Python with backslash n, okay, and
it will just use the interpreter, it comes out as
a single string, it just ignores the new line. But
if you print it from a variable, it will pick up
that new line and print it as first line second
line in this example. So if I use this copy,
puppet in there, so we're saving first line,
new line, second line into an S variable,
we just return s, it just prints out the return
statement, it doesn't do anything. But if we use
the print statement, and pass through S, then it
picks up that new line. First line, second line,
that's really, really helpful when you're trying
to format certain strings to a user maybe in an
API message, something like that. Right.
Next, we've got raw strings. So we can use
our for regular expression to print out raw
strings because you can imagine a path here
we'll have backslashes. And this example is a
great one because it got a backslash n. So if
we were to print that it's just going to Come
out something silly, because we know backslash
n is new line in a print statement. But
if we use our as a regular expression,
you can see that we see see some name has been
done, see slash some, and then it's printed out
this. But if we use reg x, then it's absolutely
fine. Okay, string literals. So you can use three
quotes, whether it be single or doubles. And that
will print out everything under that. So it's sort
of like a comment. So a comment is a hash, but
it's a single line, string literal can can span
numerous lines. And I've done that at the top of
the page here for my description, okay, so that's
what a string literal is. Copy that, dump it in
here, that will print out exactly as you want it
to be. Okay, then you got concatenated, basically
glued together. So if we use the number three,
multiplied by UN that would basically do un un
un. And then the plus symbol, the operator in
this case is concatenate. Now, glue, un un un with
our UN. So that should bring that in there. There
you go. You don't even need to use the operator
plus, if it's two strings put together like that
Python knows what you're trying to do. And it
will actually join it together. The coding really
helpful stuff. But that's really helpful when
your strings in a text or parentheses there,
span more than one line. Python knows what you're
doing. And it will just join those together. Okay.
So this only works for two literals though, not
variables or expressions, so we're gonna have an
error here, try and dump this in here. Okay, so
it's basically because we've got a variable and
a string, whereas what you need is two strings. So
prefix equals dead, and then you got prefix with
that, we then need to use the operator and then
it will work just nicely, okay, so the removing
the operator will only work for us in two strings.
That's what I'm trying to put there. In indexing.
So strings, so I keep hitting my mouse bonds
really annoying. indexing. So we need to
understand indexing for things like strings and
lists, okay. And I love this, I took it straight
from the Python website. But an index allows us
to play with certain characters in string based
on where that character is in the string by
index. So the first point in a string is zero.
And the last point is, in this case, eight or
minus one, so you can reference the string from
the front. So not one, two, or you can reference
it from the back minus one minus two minus three.
So when we're working with a word such as
dead coding, if we go word, square bracket,
zero, we're referencing the first index
of the word dead code in which would be D.
Okay, let's dump all of these in my
interpreter and see ya spits out okay?
So, so Right, so the word is
decoding. So word index zero,
that's the first as per this
diagram at the top here. 012. Okay.
Word five would be always printing out little D,
so it's not 12345. So it's D, okay, so you can
see that that's working, you can reference so if
you put zero colon, two, that will be include an
exclude, so it's include 01 and exclude two, which
is Di, include 234, but exclude five. That's what
that means. Okay? So be DCO. If you missed the
first integer, in this expression, it assumes you
mean zero. So that'll be 01 exclude two, which is
Di, if you move, if you ignore the last integer,
it assumes you mean the very last but that's
a minus one. Okay? So that will be everything
from four to the end. And then we've got
some other examples there. Okay. So we've
got minus four, so we're referencing minus one
minus two to the end, which would be Engie.
There we go. N G. And then you got you can
bring these two together so you can join them
together. So is everything up until but excluding
to and everything from to everything to the end,
you joined into it brings together decoded,
and then again, you've got another one here,
which is an example of bringing
that together. Okay. So that's
indexing is really really really helpful. So
changing strings. So if we wanted to change
so referencing the D, but assigning p it
says none and and and I type error string
object does not support item assignment
is immutable. So, if what we do is
have the string p plus word which will be
including the first. So this will be everything
from O onwards, that will work and we'll change it
to peer decoding. Or equally, we can do this. The
ID, di, di, di, okay, so we are just manipulating
strings. That's what we're trying to do and
demonstrate in this video. Okay, we use a lens. So
if we look at Bobby decoding, which is the GitHub
username, it's got 15 characters
in that using the len function
really, really helpful function,
you'll be using that quite a lot.
Handy built in functions. So when you don't need
fancy outputs, but just want a quick display of
some variables. for debugging purposes, you
can convert any value to a string with the
wrapper, or the SDR functions. So here's a list of
just some handy little functions that you can you
can use, okay, and here are some examples of what
you can do. So x, y, y 400, what you can do is
dump them in here. And that will just give you a
really handy representation of what you're trying
to achieve. Same with str, it will just change
everything to a string. Okay. And then you've got
which, there we go. So let's give those examples
there. So we've got format, okay, so this,
there's a bit of an explained explanation here.
In python three, you can use the F string, which
is F followed by two quotes. And then you can
use placeholders placeholders to add variables.
But you can also use format, which is valid for
Python two, and three. And what we're doing here
is we're doing a print statement, we're adding
placeholders. That's what these squiggly brackets
are. So it's placeholder and placeholder, and
then dot format, which is the method and it goes
in order. So the span will be injected into this
placeholder and eggs will be in that placeholder.
And equally, in a second example here, we're just
changing them around. So nor is the first item one
is the second item in this tuple. And that would
just change it around eggs and spam. Okay, so
that's my whistlestop tour of strings, there
is more to go in and do a deeper dive on
Python's website here. But do that in your
own time, do a bit of bedtime reading. Okay.
But that is the end of this video. I'm
glad that I put it together. Hope you've
enjoyed it. And I'll be seeing you
in the next video. Thank you, bye.
Okay, like always, I've got Visual
Studio Code open on my screen
in the list.pi file. So this is just one
of the pages in my supporting documentation
that we cloned out from GitHub a couple of
videos ago, we don't need the Explorer open,
we want as much real estate on the screen
here as possible. So we'll be manipulating
lists today. A list is a datatype. So
there's four different data types that
Python knows of lists, dictionaries, sets, and
tuples. I'm going to do a video on each so I don't
need to explain that explain the difference
in them, except for lists are written as a
list of comma separated values or items between
square brackets. Okay, so a list will look like
this, okay? That would be considered a list in
Python, okay? Now, lists are mutable. So, unlike
strings are immutable and tuples are immutable.
A list is mutable, you can change and alter
the items in lists. So you can identify a certain
item, and you can replace it with something else.
Okay? So they're mutable, which
is really, really helpful.
I have also added on all of these pages, if
there's any methods that are associated to
a particular let's say, data type, or let's say
numbers of strings, or anything, I've listed those
methods in the files themselves. So lists have got
methods such as append, which allows you to add an
element to the end of the list, you've got count,
extend in next reverse sort, so on and so forth.
When you have a bit more time outside of this
video, just have a tinker with lists and just
play with these methods. They're really, really,
really, really helpful. Okay, so into the basics,
we will need a terminal open and we will need
a Python interpreter interact Interactive Mode.
Okay, we've done that 100 times in this course
already. So all you need to do is fire up three
greater than symbols shows me that it's ready
for an input. So this is a basic list and we're,
we're assigning that to a variable called squares.
Okay, so dump that in here. And now we can access
squares by just doing that and it will
just print out in the interpreter,
the list okay. So that is a list in Python. Okay,
we've then got it scroll down indices. So this is
exactly the same as we went through in the string.
I haven't changed this to a list. But essentially
imagine that this is a list, you can change these
two square brackets if you like. But essentially,
each item in a list, you can reference by its
index. So in this case, this is zero, this is one,
this is two, this is three, and this is four in
the same way as in the string, you've got 0123,
and four, you can reference it from left to
right, not 123, and four, you can reference it
right to left, which would be minus 12345. Okay,
same as string. But understanding indexing is
paramount in Python is really, really helpful.
So if we put squares zero, it would turn one,
squares minus one would return 25 minus
three. So slicing, when you use a colon,
that syntax means include everything from minus
three, having a missing integer means to the end,
or assumes you mean to the end. So minus three
b naught 123. So it would return all of that.
Okay, so if we copy all of this,
we bump that in here. There you go.
There we are, right. Okay. So creating a list
copy, this is quite handy, sometimes just
open bracket, close bracket with a colon in the
middle, now do an outright copy of the list, you
can assign that to a variable, and then you can
change that copy as much as you like, it doesn't
affect the original. It's a handy way of creating
a copy. concatenation. So saying the strings,
you can glue things together, you can glue strings
together, you can glue lists together. Okay, so
if we take the variable squares, we can glue
a second list to it, and then what you've got
is a much bigger list. Oh, sorry. So I Okay,
let's go. Squares underscore two equals,
and then we'll dump that in there. If we
then put squares underscore to There you go.
Oh, my typing fantastic. So squares remains the
same, because we didn't assign to a variable,
then I did sign it to a variable called
squares to, and this then becomes this. Okay,
so that's concatenation, that is essentially
gluing two lists together, which again, is really,
really helpful. Right, you can alter items. So
unlike strings, where you can index the character,
but you can't change it in a list, you can so I
can find one bytes index, I can then replace it.
So in cubes, you can see we've got one 827 65.
That's incorrect. Okay, that should be 64. So
three to the power, so four to the power of three
equals 64. So we need to reference this by index,
which in this case is indexed three, so
it's not not 123. Or you can go minus two.
So that could just be minus two is the
same way, you're just referencing it
from a different direction. And you can
then put equals 64. So you're referencing
the item in the list and replacing it with a
new number. And then we'll print cubes again.
Okay, so now the new list is 1-820-760-4125. So
it's mutable, you can change the items by indexing
them, and then assigning them with the operator
equals. And as the same way, as we do it in
dictionaries, actually, you reference the
key using this method with the key name,
and then we use equals to assign a value.
Okay, so it's the same as in dictionaries,
list methods, so we've got a pen so accused,
we can append to one six, just do that. Hmm.
We use a pen to do an operate of seven to
the power of three. And then if we put cubes,
you can see that list has just grown by
two because we've appended to one, six,
and then 343. Okay, so we use an a method,
append, adds an element to the end of the list,
this is your cheat sheet, you'll be referencing
this page a lot in the near future. So keep adding
to it. If you find other methods are really
helpful, just keep adding to this cheat sheet
and save it and you've got it as reference point
in the future. So length, we look this in lists
is sorry, in strings, it just returns the amount
of characters or in this case by items in a list.
So that should return four because I've got 123
and four. Okay, four, really, really helpful.
Then you've got nesting. So nesting, we've got one
list ABC and D. We've got another 112 and three,
we assigned both of them within another list to
a variable X. X is a list that contains lists.
Show you what I mean. Okay, so you got
square brackets that contain one list
and a second list. Hopefully that makes sense.
So to get this list from its parent list,
you reference x with index zero, because
this is index zero, this is index one.
So x zero will return the first
list. So then if we want to get
B from this list, it would be x zero, and
then index one. So we're grabbing that list
from that list, we're then grabbing be by that
integer. And that's what we're doing here.
So spend some time understanding that it's
really, really useful with lists, but especially
with dictionaries, as well, because you might be
working with dictionaries, or Jason. And in which
case, you're referencing keyword after keyword
after keyword just to access different values,
especially with API calls and things like that.
So it's really, really helpful to understand that.
list comprehension. Now, this is a little bit
more advanced than what I would normally put in
one of these kinds of courses. But because we're
using a control flow, so we're using a for loop.
So list comprehension allows us to write this
piece of code here in one line, essentially.
So I'll just gloss over it quickly. So don't
worry about this, we'll go through control
flows in another video. But using this piece of
code, we're creating a list, I won't go through
the ins and outs of what we're actually doing and
how we're looping through. But we're creating this
list here. Okay. By using this one line of code,
which is called list comprehension, you don't
need to use multiple lines of code to create that
same list, you can just go with one line. And lo
and behold, it creates exactly the same list, but
with a much easier syntax. Okay, we'll go through
loops a little bit later. But list comprehension
is massively powerful. So please read up on it.
If you go to Python docs on this page, which is
docs.python.org/three/tutorial/introduction. It
gives you a rundown of numbers, strings and lists.
If you scroll down to the bottom near enough to
the bottom here, we've got Where Are We There we
go. 3.1 point three lists. So it goes into great
detail there. And if you do a deeper dive into
Python docs, you've got a lot more to read about
this comprehension. Okay, so, go back in Visual
Studio Code, we've then got the final bit of this
video, which is built in function, which is called
list. So this function will convert. In this case,
it's a tuple into a list. So it just takes one
object and it converts it or tries to convey
into a list if it can. So this is just a tuple.
And a tuple is defined similar to a list but
instead of square brackets, it uses just standard
parentheses. This function is converting that into
a list. So we'll change that to square brackets.
Okay, so there we go. bobby@decoding.com.
Okay, so that's my whistlestop tour of lists.
Like I said, this is geared towards beginners,
you've got supporting documentation. This is your
cheat sheet that you've got on your screen here,
read up on lists, play with lists and add to
this cheat sheet as and when you find something
interesting, you can keep referring back to
this as long as you want 2345 years down the
line in your career, and you may find something
useful. Okay. So that marks the end of this video.
Thanks for watching. I've enjoyed putting it
together. I'll see you in the next video. Bye bye.
Okay, so we're looking at tables today. This
is my Visual Studio Code instance opened up
in a tuples.py file that is contained within the
supporting documentation that you can clone down
from GitHub. Okay, there's loads of files in here.
The structure of this course is that I will just
walk you through and talk a little bit about
tuples from this form, because there's a kind
of a cheat sheet, if you like for you to use.
And we'll give you a rundown of what a tuple
is. And then we'll give you some examples of
codes, we can actually start understanding
how to work with tuples. So Python knows of
for compound data types, lists, tuples, sets,
and dictionaries. Okay, on the documentation,
it talks about lists that Tutorial for Beginners
documentation, but they don't really talk too
much about sets, dictionaries and tuples. So I
thought I'd put three videos together to help you
out. And also put the documentation together so
you can reference it. Okay, so tuples are written
as a list of common separate items surrounded by
parentheses or brackets, and like list, which is
square brackets, okay? Now, tuples are immutable,
which sets it very, very, very much aside from
lists that are that are immutable, okay, so you
can't assign items to a tuple where you can Hang
in a list. Okay, so that's an important difference
between the two tuples have two methods available,
they've got the count method and an index method.
So you have a tuple dot count will return the
number of elements with a specified value. And
tuple dot index parentheses returns an index
of the first element with a specified value.
Okay, there the two methods that we have on
tuples. Okay, so let's jump straight into a few
code examples. Open up a terminal and fire up
an interpreter. And what the first line here
is an example of what's called tuple. Packing. We
will also talk about unpacking of a tuple in a few
moments time. So what we're saying here is t to
the variable with an assignment operator equals,
and we got three items. So we've got
an integer, an integer and a string.
We're saying here that we want to assign or pack
these items to a tuple named T, because that's
the equivalent this expression is the equivalent
of doing this. Okay, we don't need those
parentheses to do it, because it's a tuple. So we
can then access the first item by index of zero.
If you don't know much about indexing,
I'll talk about that in a few moments time,
and then we'll just print it out in the terminal
in the interpreter. Okay, so T three items,
referencing the first index, which
is this one here, if we then put t,
one would get the second item in the table.
But you can see here just by printing T,
that again, that shows you that you don't
need the parentheses to pack a tuple. Okay.
Tuples can be nested. Okay, so here we've
got use or assigning t, which is a tuple,
we've got a trailing comma, and then got a fault.
We've got another tuple here, where essentially
using the package of a tuple to create a one tuple
with nested tuples. That's really what we're doing
here. So if we put U equals T, trailing comma
tuple, and then put you you can see we've got
the open parentheses here is the first tuple. And
then we've got one item, we've got another way,
okay, you can't assign to a tuple, or come up an
error type error. tuple object does not support
item assignment. Okay, that's a demonstration
of a tuple that is immutable. You cannot
assign values to items in a tuple, where you
can in a list and a dictionary and set. So
they can contain mutable objects, however,
so let's create another variable with V. And
here we put V, you got a tuple with
two lists in it. So we can now go V
first as we the first list, and then
we can say first index, that'd be one
equals two. Okay, if we now put v 223. So although
the tuple itself is immutable, the lists that are
mutable that are within the tuple can be altered,
you can assign values to items in the list. Okay,
so that's the example I've got there, you can see
that we looked at the first zero index zero index,
which which this here is the one. So this becomes
the zero index of the tuple. And that is the zero
index of the list. And we're equals using
the assignment operator to. So that's why
this comes to 23321. Okay, indexing, I've talked
about this in previous videos, but I love this,
it's really, really helpful. It just shows that if
you're referencing a string, or list or a tuple,
from left to right, then the first item in the
list or a tuple of string or so on and so forth,
is zero. Second one is 123, all the way up, so
it's going from left to right, if you reference
it from right to left, then it's minus one minus
two minus three minus four. So you have options of
actually identifying certain counters or items in
objects by that index really, really helpful. So
we can get the zero index of t, which we know is
12345, we can get the last index of t minus one,
but we know there's only three
items in a tuple. So we can also
reference the last item with two because two is
also the same index in this instance as minus one.
Okay, that makes sense. Trailing
comma. Okay, let's get this example in
here. So we're creating a variable with an empty
tuple called empty. And then we're creating.
That's I had a test in the last time I did
this. Let's do that again. do apologize. Okay,
so an empty variable. So empty becomes a variable
that contains a tuple, which is empty itself.
Singleton has just one string with a tray then
comma, that's how Singleton is going to be created
as a tuple. That's how we know we do it, you only
need a trailing comma when a tuple contains one
item. So we then use the len function to
calculate the length of empty, and we know
that there's nothing and then so it expected to be
zero. Singleton has one. So if we print Singleton,
it says hello with a trailing comma. Okay. There
we have it. And we then got unpacking of a tuple.
So at the start, we said t equals and we had
an integer, integer and a string, we can do
the opposite of that and create three variables,
I do apologize, create three variable variables
and equals t. And what that does, it does the
complete opposite. So it takes each item from a
tuple, when it signs it to its corresponding
variable in order. So x becomes index 01,
and two, so we'll expect that to be 12345. So
on and so forth. So let's go ahead and do that.
Copy. We don't need that. Okay, so is unpacked
it. So x becomes 1-234-554-3212, y and ends,
it becomes Hello, that is called unpacking a tuple
is really, really helpful when you're working with
tuples. And you'll see that in quite a lot in code
examples. Then you've got built in functions. So
we've got tuple as a function, so tuple, open
parentheses. And basically, in this example,
here, I've just got a list that contains a
whole bunch of string. And when you add the
function tuple to it, it converts that list into a
tuple. Okay, so although it starts off as a list,
by using the tuple function, it converts that
list into a tuple. And now that is immutable,
okay, we can't assign anything
to x. So if we went x one equals,
but it was a, you can't do it. Whereas beforehand,
I would have been able to because it was a list.
Okay, then you've got tuple comprehension,
which is very similar to list comprehension,
except you're, you're using the tuple
function to convert that into a tuple, as
you know, is quite, it's just an example
of how you can use the tuple function.
Okay, so that is it. So if I stick that in here,
look, it's just an example. Okay, so just use
normal list comprehension and can use the tuple
function to convert into a tuple. So I won't
go into great detail about what that's doing,
because we're using the SX. It's an example of
a control flow, which is a for loop. And use list
comprehension to change what could be five lines
of code into one easy to read line of code. That's
the list comprehension for you, in a nutshell,
but we'll look at that a little bit later. It's
kind of an advanced or intermediate kind of topic.
So let's not worry about that. So that is tuples.
Thank you very much for watching this video.
And I'll see you in the next video, we'll start
looking at sets. Okay, thank you. Bye bye.
Okay, so we're looking at sets today, you
can see here I've got a VS code instance,
open in a file called sets dot p y, if you don't
know where this is, or how to get hold of it,
then a few videos ago, we cloned down a supporting
documentation repository for this course. So get
your hands on that. And you can follow along. But
the structure of this course and these videos is
that I'm showing you and explaining what certain
things are. And then we've got some code examples
to walk you through nice and easy. So let's talk
about sets. Suppose the nodes of for compound
data types, which I'll keep repeating, because
I said at the start of all of these videos,
and it's lists, dictionaries, tuples, and
sets. Today, we're talking about sets.
You look at the documentation, they don't really
talk too much about sets in a beginners tutorial.
So I thought I'd do a video just to walk,
walk you through it and help you out. So sets,
they are an unordered collection with no duplicate
elements, like a dictionary is set as defined with
curly brackets. So sets are really handy. They're
kind of like lists, except a set cannot have
duplication. Okay, so at least you can have
duplicate item after Jukai. All day long, not
a problem, where is a set? It cannot. It has to
have unique items. So that's what's kind of where
it stands apart from lists. Now, I can talk about
this in a future video perhaps. But when you use
the set function combined with lists is really,
really helpful to look at all unique items within
a list and do a comparison and do some analytics.
Really helpful stuff. So I use sets all the time.
Anyway, so a sets a set is mutable. It's like
a list. A set is mutable, you can assign values
to items in a list, you can't in a tuple Okay, so
that's important to understand. And also sets come
with a whole bunch of handy methods. Okay, so to
add to add an element to a set, you've got clear
removes all elements from a set, so on and so
forth. I'll let you read through those methods. In
your own time, but like quite a lot of objects and
bits and pieces in Python, read up on the methods
because they can save you a hell of a lot of time.
Because if you don't know of the methods, you will
try to code that in yourself. And you might use
10 or 20 lines of code to do what essentially one
little snippet of code can do for you in seconds.
Okay, so read up on those are really, really
helpful. So code this open up a terminal and
fire up a Python interpreter. There we have it.
So all we doing is copying the code and dropping
it in here. Okay. I'm hoping it's big enough for
you to read. Okay, so here we go. Basket equals,
and then we've got curly brackets, curly brackets,
now when you're just glancing at code is easy
to get confused with a set and a dictionary
because a dictionary has also curly brackets.
But what is different in a set is that it's
just comma separated, whereas the dictionary has
key value pairs, which are comma separated. Okay,
so looking at this, I know that this is a set,
but you can see here we've got apple and Apple,
which is duplication. Okay, so if we were to
then print basket, what it does, it prints
the variable without the duplication.
Okay? Does that make sense? So although
we're assigning this set to the variable,
Python in the background is taking that set,
and it's removing the duplication, okay, but there
is some funky little ordering that they do, which
you then have to sort. But we won't
come on to that in this tutorial.
But when you're tinkering with compound data
types, you will find some weird and wacky
stuff that goes on. So you'd have to get quite
creative. So we've then got orange in basket. So
fast membership testing. Okay, so we're saying
does basket as a variable contain the string
orange, okay, which we know it does, because
we're printed out here. So we've got orange.
So we're saying orange in basket, fast
membership testing. Really, really helpful.
crabgrass says false, so it's just a Boolean,
true, false, but really helpful to understand,
okay, and then you can demonstrate set set
operations on unique letters from two words. Okay,
so we're using set as a built in function.
So we've got a set. And we've got be set
to two variables. So I put a, no put B. Okay, you
can see here that D, B, C, ra, so it's removed
the duplication of B, remove the duplication of A,
and so on and so forth. So you can say, A minus B.
Okay, so we're now comparing sets against
one another. And we're using these operators
here. So these are all of the different
operators that we can use to compare.
These are called set operations.
Okay, so we've got the bar.
So let us in all B, or both really helpful when
comparing data in these compound data types,
letters in both A and B. So we use the ampersand
symbol there. And then we're using this operator
to say let is in A or B, but not both, okay,
that's what that operator means. Okay. So
there's always do research on sets. When you're
looking at sets and lists and comparing it to and
doing some sort functions on them, it's really
helpful to understand what we're doing here,
because you can actually get a lot of output
with very little input by using these methods and
operators. Okay, so in your own time, have a
good read up. But this is your cheat sheet. So
if you find something interesting on Python or
a YouTube video, and add it in a cheat sheet,
you can always reference back I do all the time,
by the way, then you're set set comprehension.
So in the last video, I just did list
comprehension and use the, the tuple function,
but you can actually use squirrely brackets
here just to go straight into set comprehension.
There we go. Got a There we go. So we're
saying extract. So this is control flow.
So like I said in the previous two videos, so
using comprehension is allows us to create a set
or list or tuple by doing a loop of a variable
or another list or so on and so forth dictionary.
But you can do it in one single line of
code. And it's much easier to read them,
let's say four or five lines in a for loop. Okay,
there's an example in my list video. And then
you got a built in function. So we've got an set,
which we talked about a moment ago. So we've got
Bobby Bobby at decoding comm creates a set object.
There we go. So again, the ordering is all
squiffy, you know. Bobby bobby@decoding.com
I'm sure there's some logic as work comes
out like this. But we've got COMM At
decoding dot Bobby. But essentially, it's done
the work. So it's gone through that, in this
case tuple is converted it to a set and remove the
duplication. So in a background of Python is doing
that work for you. Like I say, when you're coding
hundreds and hundreds of lines of code, it's
so good that we can use these functions to really
minimize what we're doing and get the same output,
low amount of input, the same amount of output,
that is the key. And that marks the end of this
video. So thank you very much for watching. I'll
enjoy putting it together. Join me in the next
video, we'll start looking at dictionaries. Thank
you, bye. Okay, so we're looking at dictionaries
today. So I've got VS code open up on my screen,
and it's in the dictionaries dot p y file in the
supporting docs for this course, please, please,
please clone down from my GitHub repository.
If you do that, which we've gone through in
all of the previous videos, you will have a
directory that looks like this. It's essentially a
a directory tree of Python files that can be your
cheat sheet. So when you're learning Python always
reference back to these really, really helpful.
Okay, so in dictionaries.pi, structure these
videos is that I'm going to just talk about what
dictionaries are, give me some code examples,
we'll fire up an interpreter and we just
put some code in and have a little blank. Okay,
so like I said, in the last three videos, Python
knows of four different compound data types. Now
we've got lists, tuples, sets, and dictionaries.
I love dictionaries. They're like a powerhouse.
So you can store data really, really easily.
They're very similar, in a lot of ways to Jason.
So you reference values by keys, and they're just
really, really helpful, you'll be using them a
lot. So dictionaries are great for storing data
values. And it's an a key value pair. So I've got
an example of a dictionary here, but we won't put
it in the interpreter because we'll be doing that
in a second or two. But essentially, like a set,
a dictionary is referenced by curly brackets. But
unlike a set, we have key value pairs separated by
colons. So we've got a key, which is a string in
this instance, and we've got a value. So it's a
string, so it's a key value. And it's separated
by a comma. So is he dictionary is a great in
TextEdit is when they're expressed in this way.
So each key separated by a space and with some
whitespace here, and then you can have your value
is much easier to read. So the second item here,
which got a key, and then you've got a key,
this is a string, third one, we're actually
using a list as the value. And then the last one,
we've got a dictionary as a value, okay? So you
don't just have to have strings, you can have
lists, sets, dictionaries, you can use integers,
strings, whatever you whatever you like, as the
value itself. Again, dictionaries are mutable,
this means that item values can be changed,
which is important. Okay, we've then got this,
which I like, I've enjoyed putting these together,
right? So lists, sets, tuples, and dictionaries
all have a bunch of methods we can tap into.
Now, when you're coding these methods are really,
really helpful I can, if you don't know of them,
or if you've never heard of these methods, and you
might find yourself doing line after line of the
line of code, just to do the same thing as this
little snippet can do. Essentially, it would
be dictionary dot, and then you could have
clear, open bracket, close bracket, and that
will remove all elements from a dictionary, okay.
All of these methods, tinker with them in your own
time, open up a text editor, have a play, run some
code, and you will become fluent in these very,
very soon, but you got a whole bunch of things you
can tinker with. So do that. I urge you. Okay, so
let's open up a terminal and a Python interpreter.
Okay, and then we'll dump in some code.
So we'll put the dictionary that we were
talking about a moment ago in here, okay, and
we've assigned it to some decks. So we put some
debt interpreter will express a dictionary in
this way, which is hard to read. Like I said,
in the last video about sets. Sometimes you
can look at this and go oh, curly brackets is
a set or its addiction and get it wrong because
you for it to be a dictionary. It's key value.
Key value items separated by commas. A set is just
item item item, okay, but that you'll get used to
it after a while. So this is key value separated
by separated by colon. But each item is separated
by a comma. So it's key colon value, comma, key
colon, list is the value, comma, okay? You'll
get used to it. We've then got there. So this will
return an error. So if we were to unlike a list,
so if we were to reference an item in a list or
set or tuple, we could reference the item by its
index. So the very first one item in a list suit
set or tuple. You can reference by index zero. By
do that on the dict. It will come up with an error
because you don't reference items in that way.
Got key error, okay, there's no such key zero.
You need to reference key value pairs by key.
Okay, so in this case, we could put some decked
Kiera Sorry, Nakia, aka sort of referencing a key,
and a value is a value. And this one we put
a key for, we should get a dictionary back.
There we go, because we're then referencing this
really helpful. But you manage dictionaries in
a slightly different ways what you would a list
tuple, or a set, you've then got creating a dict
copy, this is one of the methods I was talking
about. Really helpful. If you want to create a
copy of a dictionary, you can then assign that
to a new variable, and you can alter it, you can
change some of the values, and then you've got
just a an absolute copy of a previous dictionary,
and the previous variable is safe, and you have to
worry about that. So again, that's quite helpful
method for you. So you've got Ultra an addict,
so we can like a list, we can use the assignment
operator and assign a new value to a key value
pair. Okay, so add the cube of six as a hangover.
I use a lot the same code examples across
these, but some decks. So what we're doing here,
we're assigning a new value to there. And then
we're printing out the value for key a key,
which is now new value. Okay, so we're assigning
a new value to a key value pair, use again, Len,
which is the len function Length function.
And that should return in this case, four,
because we got four items in a dictionary, we can
then use the keys, method, return all the keys.
Okay, you got the values method, we've sent
all the values, okay. So if you want to do
some analysis of the keys of the values or key
value pairs, you can do that by using some of
these methods, like I said, spend some time going
through them. So what we got here, keys returns a
list of containing the dictionaries keys, you
got pop, that will remove the element with the
specified key, okay, so you can specify the key
pop, and it will remove it from the dictionary.
Okay, so there's all these different fancy things
you can do. So spend some time going through that,
you've then got dict comprehension,
which is the same very similar
to list comprehension that we've we looked
at in the last few videos. So again,
I won't spend too much time about control flows,
because we're covering that in a future video.
But list dictionary to port and set comprehension
essentially means that you can create a dictionary
using just one line of code. It's much
easier to read, do your research and list a
list comprehension and dict comprehension outside
of this tutorial, I've got this example here.
So you can actually see what it's doing, or at
least understand the syntax. But if we do this,
there you go create an a dictionary with a
key of two value for key or four value, 16,
and so on, and so forth. Okay. So we're basically
looping through this tuple, and we're creating a
key, and then a value of it, we value to the
power of two. That's why we're getting for 1636.
Okay, so I'm not glossing over comprehension,
they're really, really powerful. But this is a
beginners course. And I don't want to get bogged
down in some of the bits and pieces that you don't
necessarily need to know at this point, I'll do a
future course that would be an intermediate level,
we'll start looking at comprehension
and things like that. Tips and tricks
that we've got built in function deck. So this
is on all of those forms. So you can just,
we can check. So the dict function will take keys
and values and it will just convert them into a
dict. So it creates a dictionary object. So if we
use this, there we go. So we've got a equals one,
so is a one and B two. Yeah, so it's converting
that syntax using the DAX function. And it
converts that into a dictionary, which is
really helpful, right? It saves you having
to use comprehension saves you having to
manually write that in your code base. So
I hope I've done dictionary some justice.
dictionaries are like I say, it's a powerhouse.
We use them all of the time. I certainly do. And
when you become a master on dictionaries that can
really really be helpful when you're writing
code, when you start tinkering with modules,
such as Jason is so closely aligned is really,
really helpful to understand. So that marks the
end of this video. I hope you've enjoyed watching
it. I've enjoyed putting it together and I'll see
you in the next video where we'll start having
a look at control flows. Catch you later bye.
Okay, so if statements really looking forward
to this one, I use if statements all of the
time that's fantastic, okay, I've got VS code
opening if statements dot p y, which forms one
file from the wider supporting
documentation for this course.
Download or clone it down from GitHub. Please
do that. If you're learning to code. It's always
good to have a reference point. And you can
always reference back to these files as and
when required when you're just scratching your
head a little bit, so please leave please do that.
Okay, let's move on. So let me talk about if
statements a little bit, I will try not to
butcher my explanation of what an if statement
is, and then we'll look at a code example. Okay?
If statements, so that conditional statements
right now, you and I, as human beings, we kind
of worked through lists logic, naturally in our
day to day lives. Okay? There's an if statement
is just a way of taking that logic and putting
it into your program or into your code. Okay,
so an example of that logic would be walking
down a road or down a pathway, and you want
to cross a road, okay? So you don't just die
out across the road and run across the road,
you're gonna get hit by a vehicle, right? It's not
going to be pretty. Instead, you use some logic,
okay, you approach the crossing, or your you
get to a point where you want to cross the road,
and you stop. You check to see if cars are coming.
Are there any cars coming? Yes or No? If yes,
you don't cross If no, then you may cross or
you might then say, Well, is it safe for me to
cross? If yes, cross, if no, check again, loop
through that process over and over until you are
completely safe that you are ready to cross
it? Right. Okay. It's kind of one example of
logic that you're using the real world.
You want to make a cup of coffee?
Do we have milk? Yes, we do. Make the cup
of coffee, okay, logic, and an if statement
would take that logic and allow you to use
that in your program into your code. Okay.
Probably butchered that a little bit. But as
if statements that fantastic. So think of an if
statement is a way to check to see if conditions
are met. If a condition is met, do something else
do something different. That's kind of what I was
trying to explain. Elif stands for else F. Okay,
so you do if you have elsif now and elsif is
optional. And then at the end of the statement,
you could have else which kind of a catch all.
That's optional to end if statement only needs
to consist of the if statement itself.
Okay. Both Elif and else optional. Okay,
no, it will be defined. Or I will be so it can't
read. I will be defining a function in this demo.
We'll talk about functions in a later video, but
just bear with me, okay. He may or may not know
what functions are. But this is using a keyword
def calling it number play. That's the function
name. And we've got parentheses where we're
passing through a parameter or an argument,
followed by a colon, and then this essentially,
forget the function that statement are you seeing
on the screen here, that is the if statement,
but I'm just putting it into a function so that I
can make calls against it. So let's have a
little look. So all of this here is optional,
because it's LF LF lf you don't need any of that
you don't need it is optional. But if is the start
at the if statement. So x, so x is a variable
here. So imagine x is 10. An integer. Okay,
so we're saying we're using this expression here,
which is less than So if x is less than zero,
so it's a negative number, so minus one minus
two, what we say is x equals one also is zero.
It's been a long day. And then we print negative
changed to zero. So that will appear in our
terminal or in our Python interpreter. lf, so else
if x equals equals, so this is checking to see if
x is equals to something. So saying if x equals
zero, print zero, if x equals one, print single
else. So this is the catch all. So all other
numbers, so that could be 467. So if x equals 472,
it will just print more. Okay, so that's
the kachel. So by calling this function,
if I pass through negative one, we would
expect to see this zero, then the third
one down here would be single. And the last
one would be more that could be, like I said,
that could be whatever number, it would just print
out more. Okay, so let's get out in our terminal.
Let's open up p y, Python interpreter,
and it's dump this function. There we go.
This may work I might need a little bit
more whitespace. But let's have a look.
can never be too careful with There we go.
So that's now working right? So number play.
Number play is now a function. It looks a little
bit messy in interpreter when you see these
three periods there, that's basically means that
it's expecting another line. Because a function
very much like an if statement has a colon at
the end. That means that the the actual code
appears in the next line after some whitespace.
Okay, which could be four spaces or one tab.
So function is in there. Now let's call it now
we'll call number play. And we'll call it with
an argument minus one, negative change to zero.
Okay, so let's go and we'll change it to zero.
Printing zero because this was not met. So is
there a car coming down the road? Yes, there is.
Is it safe across the road, okay? I want to make
a cup of coffee is if there's milk in the fridge
is that sugar in the cupboard? So on and so
forth. Okay, that's kind of what we're doing.
Sorry, I'm really butchering if statements
here, but I'm having fun. So, okay, and then
this last one here, there isn't actually a
number deleted it. So we can put a DLL up. It's
just a more. Okay. So that is just
a single example of if statements,
I could do so many examples of if statements
occurred, I can make this video last an hour long,
I don't need to this is a beginner's course, I'm
just trying to show you what an if statement is,
what a control flow is, how your mind should
work when you're writing code that contains
if statements, why, why and where to use them.
There is actually another video I'm going to put
together about match statements which are pretty
new to python three point 10, which kind of take
if statements to the next level, they're kind
of like a switch statement in other languages.
But if statements are kind of entry
level, so one example after this video,
don't watch anymore, open up VS code and just
start coding if statements and have a play,
you will have so much fun, you can really have
some fun with statements. So actually do watch
the rest of videos, please do but I'm just
saying have a play with statements. Right?
Okay, so that marks the end of this video.
Okay, thank you very much for watching.
I really enjoyed putting it together.
I'll see you in the next video. Bye bye.
Okay, so my VS code is open up on match.py,
because we'll be looking at match statements.
Okay, this file is one of the supporting
documentation files. So get them cloned down
from GitHub, they is your cheat sheet. So you
can always reference back to this whenever you
see fit. But I have pulled this a paragraph
from pythons own website. And this explains
exactly what a match statement is. But I will
then demonstrate match statements because I
don't think this is really kind of beginner
proof. So structural pattern matching has been
added in the form of a match statement and catch
statements of patterns with associated actions.
Patterns consist of sequences, mapping primitive
data types, as well as class instances.
That's an action enables programs to
extract information from complex data types
branch on the structure of data and apply specific
actions based on different forms of data. Okay,
so that is the official description of a match
statement. But I'll show you what it all means.
Okay, so a match statement takes an expression
and compares its value to successive patterns
given as one or more case blocks. So we have
a class in this demo. So in the code examples,
here, I've got a class, which we haven't touched
on yet, I will be putting a class video together
as part of this course. So don't get too caught
up in the actual class itself. So let's look
at this code. So I'll open up a terminal and a
Python interpreter, but essentially this look at
this function. So it's HTTP error, TPP error, and
we're passing through an argument called status,
then we've got the match statement with a
colon. So everything after that colon is
the match statement, and everything after
the case colon is a case to be matched,
or compared against, so we're passing status
through to match and then we're comparing the
status against this case statement. Does it
match yay or nay? Does it match yay or nay?
So on and so forth. Now at the bottom here,
we've got an underscore. And that's a catch all.
If the previous three cases blocks
in this instance, are not met,
then this one will match. It's kind of the
else statement in an if statement. So let's
have a look. Let's get this in a terminal in a
Python interpreter. P y, and we'll dump that in
here. Okay, so if I was to call HTTP error,
and pass through 400, we know that that will
match. So the status which is 400 will match
this case statement. Okay. So if we do it again,
plus 244, found an error, which you'd expect
because as me in that cache case, statement,
418 is I'm a teapot. But if
we were to pass through 401,
something went wrong with the internet.
That's the case. That's the catch all. Okay?
So that's kind of a very, very basic of a match
statement. You can write that as an if statement,
of course you could. And so if status
equals equals 400, so on and so forth.
But match statements come into the row when you
get a little bit more complex, and it takes a lot
less code to get the same output. I'm all about
less input, same output, or even more output.
So this example is using the bar two As an
all statements, so if status is 400 or 401,
or dented editor, then not allowed for a
zombie teapot and then a catch all again.
Okay, so let's go HTTP error, and this time we'll
go 400 not allowed, because it's part of the
case statement here. Again, if we go for three,
it'll be exactly the same, because that is part
of this isn't kind of a, an all statement. So 400,
or 4143. So if we put 418, that's me matching the,
I'm a teapot. And then if you put 500, it will say
something went wrong with the Internet. So that's
a little bit more advanced than the first one.
So we were stringing them along. And using all
patents can look like unpacking assignments
and can be used to bind variables. So point
is xy tuple. So point here is a tuple
of xy. Okay. So that's copy that.
Oh, sorry. There we go. This, I'm sharing
the screen I've got zoomed so far in,
that becomes very difficult to highlight. So I
do apologize. Let's dump that in there. Okay,
so we've now got a new HTTP error function.
And then we'll pass through we'll call
point tuple. Sorry, we'll add these two
point tuple. Okay. So we'll do the first one.
So we go, HTTP error. tuple. Origin, okay. So
that's what we're doing there. So we're just
changing the variable, point to port.
So this is 00. So that's meeting this.
Okay, what we're then doing is we're actually
assigning y. So this is what the patents can look
like unpacking assignments can be used to bind
variables. So we are binding, in this point, the
index one of the tuple, two variable y, and then
we got variable x, and we're using that as an in
an F string. Okay, so let me show you what that
means. If I'm butchering the explanation of this,
then you can have a play outside of this video
of this video. So now, if I call that again, what
we've done here, so it'd be easier now to explain
so by passing through the tuple, zero, comma 123,
and calling it with them getting this printed
out. And the reason we're getting this printed
out is because we are assigning the first
index, so which would be in this case,
in a tuple, it'd be zero and one, we're
assigning that from point to a variable y.
That makes sense. And in this case, we're
assigning it to x. So x becomes the first
point in the or the item in the tuple. And
why it becomes the second item in a tuple.
I'm, I've butchered that as well. But let's
have another go. So this will be assigning
123 to the variable x. So if I now call There we
go, x is 123. And the last, the last one is x y.
Okay, so that is matching this one here.
So x y, so we've, we're assigning the first
time to x and the second one of y is meat
in this case. So it's printing out this,
this F string, which is basically I'm using
placeholders to put the variables in. But
again, you can look into that haven't I didn't go
into that in any great detail in the string video.
But that's just one way of handling strings
with strings, and placeholders. Okay, so else,
we've got a capital and it's a value area,
not a point. Okay, so that is a little bit
more advanced match statement. And lastly, we've
got this one. Okay, so we will copy all of this
to our interpreter. Okay. So we've got a class
here, and we're using the we're importing data
class from data class, and we're using that as
a decorator. And essentially what that's doing
is adding a whole bunch of methods to the class
point, one of them is a done deal in it, you got
the report, you got all of these different things.
Don't worry about that. I've used that because
it's made this class a lot more powerful without
the need to actually code more. We'll talk about
classes and whatnot in a future video. We've then
got Where is so this is just a function. Again,
we're pointing three point, sorry, we're
passing through point as an argument, and
then we're matching point against the different
case statements. Okay, and you can see here we're
actually calling the class point. So this is where
match starts. coming into its own, because trying
to do this in an if statement would be an absolute
pain, and it will be very, very difficult to read.
But essentially, the case statement is now a call
on the Point class. So if we now pass through,
we'll call the where function and
pass through the point class with 00.
We get an origin. Okay? That makes
sense. So we're calling the function,
we're passing through an instance of the class
with two arguments, zero and 10. And it's just
giving you all of it is matching the cases,
we don't necessarily need to go through this.
But what I've essentially given you here is a
cheat sheet on match. It's very, very new. There's
not many videos out there, I've probably butchered
match. But what you what you've got here,
what you've got here is just some very, very basic
to intermediate examples of how match statements
are differentiated between if statements, okay, so
you can, you are still matching, you'd still check
in a parameter or an argument against a case or a
statement. And if it meets, then you do something
very much like an if statement in that regards,
but you can do so much more. And when you get
used to them, you can write some pretty complex
match statements that are very easy to read,
which is important. So okay, that's my video on
Match statements. I hope it was clear and concise,
please, please get the supporting documents from
GitHub. And you can have a play in your own time.
But the important one is this one here, but
classes because you'll be using that quite
a lot when you get more advanced. Thank you
very, very much for watching. I hope you've
enjoyed it. hope it's been useful. And I'll
see you in the next video. Thank you. Bye.
So my Visual Studio Code has opened up on
a loops dot P why? Because we're looking at
for loops, we're looking at while loops today.
So controls control flows. This file is part of
the supporting documentation that you can claim
from GitHub, please do have a look at that. And
that's half a go of explaining what loops are. And
then I'll give you some code examples that we can
actually practice on. So pythons for statement
iterates over items in a sequence. So give me a
list a set a tuple, a dictionary or a string. And
it iterates in the order in which they appear in
a sequence. Okay, so at layer two a from left
to right. If you were to then sort that list,
for instance, whatever the result of the sort
is, it would then iterate left to right. Okay,
so it's important to note that, so the built in
range function comes in really handy when you
want to iterate over a sequence of numbers,
or a length of numbers or length of an item,
as it generates arithmetic progressions. So
the range function can just take one integer,
and that is the stop argument. Okay,
so it has a start a stop and a step.
Okay, if you don't pass a step, sorry, a start
point, it will assume you mean zero. So the
integer that you pass through to a range is always
the stop. If you pass through a third integer,
that will be the step. Okay? So a start
is the value of the Start parameter,
zero, if you if you fail to pass it through value
as the start and the step is, how many steps
you want to do, I've got some examples of it
that will that will kind of hit that one home,
then we've got a very basic example of a loop.
So we're creating a list here. So it's got cats
got window, and then they've got defense straight.
Okay, so we've got three items in the list. Okay.
Four is what we use when we want to do a for
loop. So we want to loop through each item in this
expression in this in this case, you could
use a string, but this is a list so it's
cat window. Defense, right? Okay. And then we're
assigning it to a variable. Now that very can
be any anything you want, is a variable. So I
thought when I first started coding in Python,
or coding in general, that that variable had to
be W because words starts with W, it doesn't, you
can call that horse house, parrot, Bobby, whatever
you want. Every time you loop through that list,
the the item, the resulting item is assigned
to that variable. So it can be whatever you
like. Okay, so the first loop would be cat, W is
assigned the string cat. So when we then print W,
we're printing W, just cat and the length of that
string, which is three. So the result will be cat
three, the second loop will be window, so
it would be window. Six, and then you'd have
defense straight, which is I think
it's 10 or 11. So be done with defense,
right and then the length of that string. So
okay, let's dump that into a Python interpreter.
There we go. Thumper in. There we go. So like I
say, cat three, window six and different always 12
sets of length was 12. Okay, so that's what we're
doing that very, very basic. But the for loop,
like I said, at the top, you're just looping
through every single loop, you're assigning what
is found as an item or a character, whatever the
case may be, you're assigning it to a variable,
you can do something with that variable, you
can print it, you can do a sum on a number,
you can assign a variable to a key value pair and
addiction, eight, whatever you like that you're
doing a for loop, you can nest an if statement
in there and do something based on a condition
you can nest and match statement in there, based
on a case statement. The world is your oyster.
Okay, so create a sample collection. So let's have
users Well, we do in here, create a dictionary
called users. Okay, so we've got queen,
active, Eleanor inactive, John active.
So this is a dictionary, the content contains
users, and their status, active or inactive.
Okay, what we've then got is iterate over a copy.
So we're making a copy of users, again. So we're
making a copy of that dictionary. Remember,
that was a method that we looked through,
in the dictionary video that I did a few videos
ago. So four, so four, for each user status. So
you work with dictionaries in a for loop, in
a set, or tuple, or list or character for it's
just one variable. But because we are looping
through key value pairs, you need to express it
in this way. So for each key value, in this case,
we just call it you can call a key value, you can
call them user status. In this case, I like to use
key value doesn't matter for each user status. So
use that status, user status, user status, in a
copy of users, dictionary dot items. So these are
the items each item in a dictionary. Okay, so
what this expression here is basically saying,
that's one item. So we're looping through
that. But we're assigning it to Quinn. Active
user status. Next item, Eleanor inactive. Next
item, John active. I hope I'm kind of explain what
this means. This is a dictionary, so we looked for
it slightly different. It's essentially what I'm
saying. Then I've got an if statement. So we've
got an if statement in here to say that if status.
Yeah, so that's the variable. So if status in this
case, active equals equals inactive, do something.
In this case, we use the delete
function, this will actually delete users
user. So we're referencing the item by the
keyword, which in this case will be Quinn.
So if the status is inactive, well, that condition
hasn't been met, so it won't do anything. So it
does another loop. So do another loop. The
second loop, Eleanor, if status is inactive,
delete it. So we will delete that because that
condition was met. And then we'll do a second
a third loop. If John is active, we won't do
anything. So the resulting copy of users because
this is a copy of the dictionary will just
be two items Quinn active John active, okay.
Okay, so if we go users, there we go. So
that's exactly what we would have expected.
So the inactive user has been deleted from the
dictionary. That's what we just done. Okay,
so create a new collection. So the new collection
is an empty dictionary called active users.
So this time, we are going to do a for loop over
users items. So this is the original dictionary.
It's not a copy. And this one, this time,
what we're doing is we're saying if the active
then add the key into the empty dictionary
with the value status, so we're creating a
new dictionary. Okay, so if doing the same for
loop, except we're now checking that if the
user is active, if the user is active, then we're
creating a key value pair and we're adding it into
the dictionary. That's how it works. If it finds
the key, it will use assignment and it will assign
the value to the key value pair. If it can't
find the key it will add a new key value pair.
Okay, then we've got range
sis have a little Tinker
Okay, let's dump that in here. So for
i in range five print I was that done?
That's really, really helpful. Okay, so for i in
range five. So remember, we've just, we've just
put one argument in the range function. Remember
I said that the start would be assumed to be zero,
and we haven't used a step. So the one integer
with pass through is the stop. So we've added
five, the first iteration of that range is
always zero when we use in indices, so 01234,
that's four loops of the range function, it's
where it's really helpful, then what we can
do is the start stop, remember, so if we do two
integers is start start, if we do three integers,
it will be zero, 10, three. So let me walk
you through this because this is interesting.
So this is a start stop. So the first one is five,
and then it stops at 10. And when we're 10, would
be nine, because if we did from zero to 10, it
will be 0123456789. So because we started at five,
it's five to nine. Yeah, get that. And we use
the list function to then convert that range into
a list. We've then got naught
10, three, so start at zero,
finish at nine, so it's, so finish at 10. So it's
not 12343 to nine. So yeah, we've got 10 integers
not to nine, but we're doing steps in three. So
it's only show every third step, or every step
of three in the range. So it starts at zero, then
it's 123, then it's 456789. So that's where the
step function comes into it. And then you've got
another example using negative integers. Okay,
so start at negative 10. Finish at
negative 100, in steps of 13, so is 10
minus 10. So minus 20 3040 minus 50 6070. Okay,
it's really helpful to know. So we then have Mary
Had a Little Lamb or sign in that as a list to
variable a. And then we're saying for I, to copy.
So let's see what we've just done
that, see if I can explain it.
So for i, so remember, that variable could
be anything we want. So for Bobby, in range,
Len a select the length of A, that would be
12345. So remember, where and we're adding Len
a into the range function. So that's, that will be
an integer of five. So for range five, so 01234,
that a five Ranger print the variable, which will
be Mary Had a Little Lamb, followed by a integer.
So i is the i is those not 1234. So it's not
and then we're returning the index, not from a.
But makes sense. So this is the list. And the
zero index is marry, the one index is had,
and so on, and so forth. Have I got that in here?
I haven't. Let me open up lists, show you there we
go. That's what I wanted to show you. So indexing,
I was losing myself that indexing is really,
really helpful. There's a little diagram here of
what it means to a string or a list. So the first
item in the list is zero index 01234.
So the first loop would be range zero,
in the list would be Mary, and so on and
so forth. Okay, so we don't need list open.
So that's what we've done there. And then we've
got some range for and that some range for
six. Okay, so what I was doing is not four,
so it's not 123. So zero plus one, plus two,
plus three equals six. That's what that's doing.
Okay. So it's loop some itself is looping through
the response of range for an insane zero plus
one plus two plus three equals six. That is what
that's doing. So I've given you a whistle stop
tour of for loops, or looping and conditionals
statements in Python, I hope it's been beneficial.
Spend some time doing it. So you now know if
you've been following along with this course
we've gone through if statements match statements,
we're now going through for loops, we've gone
through strings, lists, dictionaries, tuple, sets,
and everything in between. Now you're starting
to get enough tools in your toolbox to actually
start coding so please have a play reference this
document outside of this video and just start
tinkering, start programming. Okay, so for loops,
very, very important. And it's hugely, hugely
helpful when you're programming. So this marks
the end of the video. I hope you've enjoyed it.
I hope it's been useful and I'll be seeing
you in the next video. Thank you bye bye
Okay, so loot clauses today. We are looking at
these now because we looked at loops in the last
video. So look clauses is a natural progression
from that. Visual Studio code is opened up on
loop clauses dot p y, which is one of the files in
the supporting documentation. So close that down,
it is a cheat sheet for you to use. So let's
talk about what loop clauses are. So Python
has a few statements or clauses that we can use in
loops. They include break, continue else and pass.
Okay, so loop statements may have an else clause
it is executed when the loop terminates for an
exhaustion of an iterable. As for a for loop, or
when a condition becomes false with a while loop,
but not when a loop is terminated by a break
statement. So what does that mean as a beginner
is difficult to understand. So I've got some code
examples to walk you through it. Okay. So this
is a little bit more complex in terms of a for
loop. So I'll try and walk you through it. Okay.
So we'll put this in interpreter as well. But this
little statement here follows. So we know range,
we're possible, we're starting to stop. So for
n in range to 10 is the equivalent same for n
in this little bad boy. So they say
it's a list 123456789. So the first
iterable is to the first time it does
a loop it assigns to to the variable n
keep the end in mind, the second for
loop. So every time it does a loop,
it then goes through this part of the code,
okay, this part of the for loop. Okay?
So this is for x in range two, so a starting
point is two, and the end point is a variable n,
which we know is two, because that's the first
one. So range two, two, is the equivalent of
a list that looks like that. It's got
nothing in it, okay, so it hasn't got an
x becomes nothing essentially is nothing right.
So, there is nothing there is no loop to be had.
So when we then do this if statement, so if
an A and modulus x equals equals zero, well,
the comparison isn't there. Because you know,
comparing one against something that isn't there,
equals equals zero. So that isn't false, that
condition is not met. So it does else print
statement on a prime number. The second loop
is a three, so this range becomes two, three.
Okay. So it then compares that statement, if
it's matches, so if modulus x equals equals zero,
then it prints this statement here. So n
equals x, there's got little string of star,
then it's prime. So it's floor division, NX.
Okay. So let's have that in our we've learned
all about floor division in numbers right at the
start of this course, you should understand what
we're doing here. So copy this go terminal new
and do this and dump it in. And what we have,
there we go. So we expect it to to be a prime
number because the condition wasn't met, we
expect three to be a prime number, okay? And then
it's four. So the print statement is four equals
two times two. Okay? So it goes through,
that's what that's doing is a basic kind of
for loop was followed with a for loop with
an if statement. So it's not basic at all.
But we've got a little break statement here.
So it prints out and then it breaks. So that
for loop finished, so it does the loop again.
So that's what the break statements doing.
Okay, so continue statement. So for now I'm in
range 210. Okay, so if num, modulus two equals
two, then do something and it continues.
So this will continue with the next loop.
Okay, so this is another example. So it's
just doing something slightly different.
So found an even number or an odd number, bound
and even found an odd found an even found an odd,
right from the to through tonight. Then you've
got a past statement. past statements are really,
really useful. When you're coding, you might
write classes or functions that you need to
call in another function, but you don't
want it to do anything. Because you're
not actually at that point of the code
yet, you might be testing something
past just means that it does nothing, it doesn't
break or anything like that is just allows you to
I can call my past class and it won't do anything.
Okay. So this is an example of a function you can
add to pass and I can call that function. So my
pass death. Okay, it doesn't do anything because
it's just got past statement if it didn't have the
past statement, and it'll come up with an error.
Actually, it will show you in a text editor here
that you can't do that. It just doesn't let you
do it. So that is closed loops. Again, like
with this course, I'm explaining what they are.
I'm giving you some code examples all that have
been extrapolated from pythons own documentation
for you to read up in your own time and have a
tinker and kind of understand what I'm doing.
What pythons doing. I have tweets Some of
them. But yeah, that is Luke closer hope
you've enjoyed this video that is the end of this
one. I'll see you in the next video. Thank you Bye
okay modules today, so it won't take long to
explain what modules are. So before we jump into
it, my VS code is opened up in the modules.py
file. You can reference this whenever you like,
look, it is your cheat sheet, but you can get the
supporting docs on GitHub. So all of that will be
in the description. Okay, so module so in Python,
we're able to write a long program and save it as
a module. This is known as creating scripts, we're
able to input modules across modules and into the
Python interpreter, right. So what you don't
want to do is write a function numerous times,
what's the best situation is to just write it
once and do not repeat yourself. The reason for
this is because if your function is incorrect and
not working correctly, you need to debug it. If
you've got to hit multiple currencies or that
function across your project, you need to debug
all of them, what you need to do is create one
function and import it as a module to your other
application or other file in your project. So
do not repeat yourself dry. That's what this is,
you may see that a lot in your career. Python,
Python standard library can be found here, they've
got a whole bunch of modules and fancy stuff
that you can import and take advantage of. Please
look at that your own time, we've got it here in
modules, have a look at this page. And it talks
about different modules. So import flow, which
is the Fibonacci module, there's loads and loads
of different modules you can import. But we're
not going to look at those. Today, we're going
to look at our own that we've already created. So
in the last video, we were looking at functions,
and we create a function called Demo funk in
the functions file. So that's a script that we
can import. So if you look here, I've got from
functions import demo funk. Now, that will print
out some gobbly goo closer to us because it's got
some other functions in the file. But essentially,
with this line of code here will allow us
to import that function. So we can call
it and pass it through to these functions.
Let's get that open up a terminal, open up
a interpreter. We dump it in there. Okay. So we've
imported demo funk, and yet it's printed out a
load of two's because we've got some functions in
there, don't worry about that. It just now means
that we can access demo funk, so we can say my
int equals demo funk. And we'll pass through 28.
Okay, so my int now becomes data because that
function is taking an integer addition, adding
on six and then returning the new calculation.
So we're expecting 32. But what we can do,
we can now pass that through to my funk one,
so we can say my funk will pass through my int
my funk, what we're talking about is funk one,
funk one, my ENT. There we go, do apologize.
Okay, so you can see how we're importing
a module. And when we're using that module
to interact with other functions. Now we
can import funk one into another module.
Does that make sense? We you know, you can, it's
so important to make sure that your code is as dry
as possible, do not repeat yourself is really
important. So we then got funk, too. So funk
underscore two, is that
right? Funk underscore two,
we won't we won't use the demo funk this song.
This is actually yes, we will. We'll go my int.
And this is this has given us the power of so
my in this case it will be 32 to the power of
16. Well, that's a big number. But that's a good
explanation of modules. Okay, that like I said,
So pythons standard library can be found here
on this page. So if you look here on Zoom In,
I was not working. It's not liking
that. Yeah, there you go. docstoc
python.org/three/tutorial/modules.html.
That's where you'll find this standard
library or documentation about their standard
library, their link to the library is
whereas it let me crash that out. Or there
we go. Can you see that on the screen? Yeah,
Doc's dot python.org. Three dash load library.
So actually, that's open that in the browser.
There we go. So you've got a list of everything
in here. Okay, so text position services. We've
got Date Time, which is which is a great
one. So you'd say import In the terminal
p y said say import, Jason,
he say import, daytime.
Or you can go further and save from Date Time
import, I think is delta. Now there isn't, there
is a date time actually go from date, time, import
date time. So these are different functions and
classes and stuff within those packages. So have
a good read up on all of these. They're fantastic.
Again, like the methods in lists and things like
that, when you really understand this, it can
save you lots and lots of time when you're coding.
So that marks the end of this video. Hope you've
enjoyed it hope it's been very beneficial. And
I'll see you in the next video. Thank you, bye.
Okay, so we're nearing the end of this course. Now
we're looking at classes in the next video. And
we'll look at a small bit of programming a little
API that we're right, that comes after this,
which is all about exceptions and errors. So my
VS code is opened up on errors dot p y, this is
your cheat sheet, you can clone this down from
GitHub, always reference back to this is really,
really helpful as a programmer. So Python has
at least two distinguishable kinds of errors.
So you got syntax, you got exceptions, okay, as
a noob, you'll be getting a lot of syntax errors,
you'll not need to look at colons after functions.
And if statements and loops, you need to look at
whitespace loads and loads of problems. But
that's where text editors are really, really
helpful. So look at my text editor video, get
one installed, we've got VS code in this course,
syntax errors. As you become better, you'll know
what the errors are. So exceptions are and you'll
know how to handle them. So I've got all of the
exceptions here. So you got name of exception
description about what it actually means. Okay,
so we'll be having a look at some of these. We've
already seen some of these during this course.
But some of the bottom here you got type error,
you nightmare, you got zero division error, okay?
So work through them when you got a bit of time.
But we've got here some examples of code that will
be coming up with an error, okay, so if we get
p y here, dumping some code, this will be
zero division, because 10 times one over zero
is zero division raised when a second operator
in a division is zero, you've got four plus spam
multiplied by three, well, spam doesn't exist. So
I've got a name error, if I put spam equals two
in our exists, so we don't get the error, then
we've got a string plus integer doesn't like that,
okay, but if we go to plus two, it will like
that. There are exceptions. So now we need to
look at how we can handle exceptions. So we've
got a little while loop here and my example.
Let's get that dumped into the interpreter and
see what's going on. So we've got a while loop.
So while true, you do a try and accept statement.
So I haven't talked about trying to accept
statements, you can read up on them on Python
docs. But we've got one in here. So essentially,
it's trying to run a piece of code. But we accept
that if any of these exceptions occur when running
the code, we print this, okay? So this, this code
could say anything really, but basically, we're
trying something we've got a break clause there,
and we're accepting if these exceptions occur,
then we do something. So this is how you manage
exceptions. So if we were to run a try and accept
on the code earlier, we could say if there's zero
division error occurs, then do something else you
can just print a fancy statement, okay, so we put
five in here it won't have an error, okay. But if
we would find narrow then it will do this it will
print Oops, that was not a valid number try again.
Okay, so then we've got a function
try this fails, so we say this
BIOS division error, okay, so one
over zero division error, but if we
stick it in a try accept statement and Bonga in
here is calling this file so try this file. So
we're calling the function and we're accepting
zero division error. Okay, and because we're
accepting that, we can then say what happens
in this case we just did a print statement
handling runtime error division by zero. Good so
the train except statement has an optional else
clause which can be present must follow an except
clause is useful for code that must be executed
if the try clause does not raise an exception.
Okay. So if a finally finally clauses present
finally clause will execute a last task before
the try statement completes. The finally clause
runs whether or not the try statement produces
it as an exception. The following points discuss
more complex cases when an exception occurs.
So let's get this little function in here.
Okay, well, we got several get it all on the
screen. So okay, so we've got a function called
divide, and we're passing through two positional
arguments, x and y. Okay? So it must have two
arguments. So we're trying result equals x divided
by y. So that is what we're trying. That's the
little bit of code we're trying to run. But we're
saying except, if we receive a zero division
error, then we just print that we get type
error must be an in if we else print result is
result. Okay? So result equals, and then finally
we print executing, executing. Finally, finally,
clause, tongue twister. So that will be printed
anyway. Okay, so if we now pick up those commands,
and dump them in here, you should see
an example. Oh, I didn't like that.
Do apologize, as pick this up, copy.
Delete that. stumped them in. Okay, so the
first example, divide to one result is two,
okay? Because one is an integer above zero,
so we don't get the zero. And what does it
say? So the result is two. So this actually
it tried it, okay. So result equals x over y
to zero, that is a zero division error. So
we're getting division by zero, then we've got
strings instead of integers, it's
printing out must be an integer.
So they're the three times we've
called it but you know, is every time
we get an executing finally clause, that's
because this is run every time it tries. Okay,
so this is the finally clause. And that's what
we're talking about in here. Okay, so that
is a save the changes I made. That is a whistle
stop tour of errors and exceptions. I hope this
made sense is really, really helpful. You'll find
a lot of this when you're reading other people's
code, people that have been coding in Python a
lot, you'll find a lot of this type of stuff.
So try to understand it, read up on the exceptions
on the Python website, understand what they do and
what they are and how to handle them. And you'll
be good to go. That's the end of this video. I'll
see you in the next video where we will start
to look at classes, or certainly I'll try to
catch you later. Bye bye. Okay, so looking forward
to this one, because classes are the cornerstone
of OOP or object orientated programming in Python.
Okay, we looked at functions a few videos ago,
and I said that look at a function as a container,
you have some script, what have you, when you save
that container, you can call it and you give it an
input, you get an output, okay, we do some fancy
stuff in the function, but essentially, his input
and output class goes so much more further than
that, it gives you the ability to bundle data,
and functions together, they are a powerhouse,
okay? And unlike any other datatype in Python,
okay, so not that you can store data in
dictionaries, and lists and what have you. But
classes gives you the ability to store data and
give it functionality at the same time. So if you
look at VS code, on the screen here, I've got open
on cluster dot p y, which is one of the files in
the supporting documents that you can clone down
from GitHub. This is your cheat sheet. So please
do that. It's massively helpful when you're coding
and looking back, forget certain things. This
could be your reference point. So please do
I've extrapolated a whole bunch of data
from pythons own docs, which are in docstoc
python.org/three/tutorial/classes. They go
into great depth about classes, objects, names,
namespaces, inheritance, base classes, instance
variables, class variables, and everything in
between. Okay, so a bit of bedtime reading view.
This course in this video is all about beginners,
and helping you get started. So you can
start tinkering and coding. So this is very,
very much geared towards beginners, and I've just
extrapolated what I think is what you need to know
to start. So classes provide a means of
bundling data and functionality together,
creating a new class creates a new type of object
allowing new instances of that type to be made
Python classes by all the standard features
of Opie the class inheritance mechanism that
we'll look at soon allows multiple base classes. a
derived class can override any method of his base
class or classes. And a method can call a method
of his base class with the same name. That's all
about inheritance. It frames it very, very well,
but I'll walk you through that in a few minutes.
simplest form of a class definition looks
like this. So you have a class keyword,
followed by class name, colon, and you
have a bit of whitespace in all of this
And these your methods and class variables, okay?
So look at that in a second have a function,
you must save or a D must define a class before
you can make, or before it takes any effect.
So let's look at some of my class examples here.
Let's open up a terminal and a Python interpreter.
So we'll dump this in the interpreter quickly. So
we've got my class available. So class keyword,
and you got my class, colon, and then you've got
some of this, the first line here is text literal,
I would urge you, I urge you to added texture to
all of your classes. Because if you're looking
back at a class that you wrote years ago, or
somebody else's code, they may if it hadn't
got a text literal, there's no way of knowing what
that class does without really doing a deep dive,
where you can call a magic method called doc,
and it will tell you exactly what's going on.
Mine's very simple, but you can put whatever
you want in there, it could be 200 lines,
if you like, you then got a class variable,
which is accessible to all instances of a class,
which I'll give you an example of in a
second. And then you got the F method, just a,
we're just calling it f, we call it anything
you like. But that is a method for this class
that can be called Okay, and it will just
return a string called hello world. So we
can now call my class I and get back the integer
12345, we can call F and get a function method.
Okay, and we can call the magic method doc to
get the string literal. Okay, so you can call
double underscore doc dollar, double underscore
any class and it will return the string literal
if it has one. So let's go ahead and instantiate
this class and assign it to a variable x. So the
class is now instantiated, and we can access it
using a variable x. So again, we'll go extra I
move my mouse X to Y, we have access to 12345,
which is a class variable. Now, if we go x dot F,
but this time we have parentheses, it will pass
it will bring hello world. The reason is bringing
back hello world is because we are parsing
through self. Let's talk about that. So we pass
the methods instance object in as the
first argument of all methods. So x dot F,
which is what we called here, is the equivalent of
saying a my class dot F, and in passing through X,
okay, self has no special meaning
in Python, the word self doesn't,
it's just his normal convention to do so. So
in this class, we're possibly self. So that
is where we're instantiating all of this to x.
And then the first argument and the method is
x itself. That's how we can act. That's how we
can access that method and call that method. Okay.
Hope that makes sense being see we're doing
it again here. So we expanded on our class.
Let's get that in here. And talk about it text
literal, no change, but we're now using a new
magic method or Dunder init method called in
it. And we're passing through self, which we do,
because we pass through the instance itself or
the object itself. And then we're passing for
a positional argument called My int. And it has
to be an integer. Okay, so if I didn't have this
in there, you can pass or anything, but it won't
like it because we're actually using an integer as
a sum. So that's what that's doing. And within
that method, we are assigning my integer to a
instance variable called self dot i, okay. So
that is only accessible to the instance itself.
So whereas the first example, I was a class
variable, this is an instance variable. And
then with the F method, we're just doing a
quick sum. So new variable equals, we get any
integer that we're passing through as a keyword,
positional argument, and we were doing a sum,
which is the power of three. So if we pass
through four, it's four times four times four,
which is 64. And we're returning. So that's
instantiate the class to x again. Now x.ai
is four. It's not 12345. Now because we passed
four through as the positional argument, okay.
Now, if we go x dot F, is 64.
Okay, so we're calling this method,
it has access to self.ai, because we're passing
self through as the instance. So x is accessible
in F. Self that I, that makes sense? I hope it
does. So we're passing the instance through as
the first positional argument is doing assignment
is returning the new sandwich is 64. Good.
Now let's talk about adding an attribute so we can
add an attribute to our instance called counter.
It's not in the class, we're just adding
this To the instance of the class,
so now we have access to x dot counter,
which should be one. If we were to do a
little while loop, just on the sum. So while
x dot count is under one, we do something.
And then so we changing count to another number
in every loop, we just checks. Is it on 10? Is it
under 10? Is it under 10 hours over 10. Now stop.
That's what a while loop is doing. So essentially,
I put a description. So the first loop returns
two, because it's one multiplied by two,
and then x becomes two. So it's two times two is
four, four times two is eight. Eight times eight
is 16. And at this point, it hits the loop and
says, ah, 16 is above 10. So stop, so loop then
stops, so the fifth loop does not happen. So we
know that x is 16, down here. So if we print x,
it will be 16. But now we can delete that
attribute of the instance x by using Dell. Now,
if we try and print it again, it just won't like
it. Okay? It won't like it. But what we can say is
attribute or we can call it,
attribute to ohms. And we didn't assign
anything. Yeah, X attribute so and then we can
find out Yeah, we could do another
someone else. But then we can go del
x dot attribute, do an L delete it, and then we
don't have it. Okay. So once we've instantiated
a class, we can add attributes, remove attributes
really, really helpful. And you can't do that with
dictionaries or anything like that, you can,
you can add data to dictionaries. And because
they're mutable, you can change values and things
like that. But with classes, you get so much more
that you can tinker with. So now let's talk about
in a little bit more depth instance variables.
So you can actually understand it a little bit
more, let's create another class called Dog.
Now, what we're doing is a class variable that's
available to all. And I've got instance variables
that are only available to the instance. So when
we instantiate the class, we will have access to
a name and tricks variables. And then we've got
a method called add trick, and we pass through a
trick and it appends it to this list of the
instance variable, not the class variable.
Okay, so don't count the class variable is
canines, every instance of this class will have
a variable called kind, and that will be equals
to canine. So let's create an instance assign it
to D. Okay, in this instance, I'm gonna assign it
to E. So D has the name Fido and he has the name,
buddy, because we're passing through a positional
argument called name. So you have to pass a string
through. Actually, you know, you don't even pass
anything you like through, but we could do that.
We could do that. And it has to be a
string. Okay, let's save that. So he kind,
d dot kind will be exactly the same. This is
a class variable, but e dot name, we buddy,
d dot name will be five eight, because that is
specific to the instance. Now we can go one step
further, we can assign a trick to D. And it'll be
specific today, we can assign another trick to a
and all this is doing is taking that string,
and it's appending it to the instance next
list, which is an instance dict. So a list is
not a class list. That was a class list and we
added roll over and play dead, then both instances
will have access to those tricks in this case. So
we now put D we don't want that. We want it down
here d dot trick you can see. Sorry, the dot trick
was tricks side. There we go. D dot tracks,
rollover a dot Trix. Play dead. So we can then add
another one to a ATREX. It's now got two in there.
Dietrich's still got the one because we're only
using instance variables. Okay, does that makes
more sense? So we instantiate in more than one
class and we tinkering with those instances of
that class. So let's talk about inheritance.
Oh, let me just come back in here and make some
changes. Inheritance so the class can inherit
from other classes. Okay, so base classes now you
can inherit from numerous different base classes.
Indeed, a base class can then inherit from another
base class. Now this is really handy when you're
trying to write clean code, because what you don't
want If duplication of methods across numerous
different classes, it's good to have a base class
that has common attributes and methods that you
can use elsewhere. And you can then inherit
from the derived class from a base class. So
think of it as kind of a, a tree so that you have
a base class, which two classes can inherit from,
or two or more, and, and so on, and so on and so
forth. Okay. So for instance, this example here,
this dog class, could inherit from the
animal class. Because a dog is an animal,
you could have a class called Cat, that would
also inherit from the animal class. And that
animal class could have a whole bunch of methods
in there that are useful to derived classes.
I've got another example here. So actually,
this is an example of a derived class,
he got the class name, and you got a bracket and
all of the classes that is inheriting from, okay,
and then again, you then state you're
the same, you're doing a normal class.
But remember, a derived class can overwrite the
methods of its inherited classes. For instance,
the dog class might have a special method, or a
special way of handling the tail method that is
different to a frog that doesn't have a tail or
loses its tail when it goes from tadpole to Frog.
That's quite a good explanation of methods and
overriding Okay, so execution of a derived class
definition precedes the same as for a base class,
when a class object is constructed, the base
class is remembered, this is used for resolving
attribute references. If a requested attribute
is not found in the class, the search proceeds to
look for that base class or in that base class,
this rule is applied recursively if the base class
itself is derived from another class, so it keeps
looking and looking and looking recursively
derived classes may extend or override methods
from the base classes. Okay, so really, really,
really helpful. And it allows you to write really
clean code. Otherwise, you could have one class
that is crazy long, and then you're duplicating
some of those methods in another class that is
crazy long as best to have two smaller classes,
a base class that they both feed from. Okay,
so I've got a couple of classes here that
kind of walk you through that. So there's open
dump all that in my interpreter. And let's see
if we can walk through this. Okay, so we've got
mapping, that is our base class, in this example,
private variable example. So check out
double underscore update. This is called
name mangling. There's a bit about name mangling
in pythons own Docs. So have a look at that.
It's, that's what that's the example.
Actually, they're using our own Docs.
So but we don't necessarily need to do need to
talk about that in great detail at all in this
explanation, it basically means that this
update can appear where it appears in a class
is done without regard of syntactical syntactical
position. So normally, you can only access certain
variables because they appear above them. So but
because we're using name mangling, we can access
update, no matter where we put it. So do a deeper
dive of that, and Python docs that's a bit beyond
beginner level. So mappings got a special method
called in it. And we've got items list and
iterable. As instance variables, we then got
an update method. So for item in self iterable,
we have access to self editable, because it's
an instance variable, we then append it to this
empty list of the instance. Then we've got
a class called mapping subclass. And we,
which derived is a derived class. And a base class
in this case is mapping which is the class we've
just talked about here. So this inherits from
mapping. But you can see here we're overriding
the update method again, so that we've got it in
here. This mapping subclass is actually got its
own method called Update, which would do its own
thing. Okay, so, so don't worry about the actual
functionality of the methods and what
they're actually doing. And a result,
don't worry about that, just more or less, just
look at what we're actually doing here with the
class and the inheritance. Okay, that's the
whole point in it. So we will instantiate
mapping subclass, and we'll, we'll call that
or we'll assign it to a variable called M.
Okay? So we can then say M items list.
Okay. So the instance variable is an empty
list. We will then call update. So in
this case, we call an update and it's a
list 123 And another one these are values
okay, so now we can quite simply add that
and it will create one These two are three
values. Okay? So what it's doing, it's,
it's creating what we're doing here. So, okay,
there's talk about the method and what we're doing
because it's actually quite confusing. Okay, so
we've got two lists, we've got 123. And these are
values. So what this update method is doing, it's
for item in zip, and what we're doing that that is
a built in method called Zip. And it basically
zips, two lists together to key value pairs.
And then what we're doing is we are using self
dot items list to append item to the list that
we just created in the instance variable.
So that's why we've got a tuple. One, these
two are three values. That's why we've got that
result. So but if we were just calling the update
method, we wouldn't get that because all it's
doing is it's iterating. Through what we're
passing through, in this cases, it's a list in
a list. And it's just self items dot append,
and it's just appending the item so we'd
get a very different result if we weren't
superseding the update method. Okay, I don't
know if I've just butchered that inheritance
explanation, but it's a beginners class.
So hopefully, that's given you enough to
actually work. I mean, I've just used the zip
method there. And, and I probably could have
gone with a much more simple explanation. But if
we were just using the base class update method,
it would do one thing, but because we are
actually overwriting that update method,
we're doing something very, very different.
Okay. So that is the end of this video,
they are all of my code snippets that we've walked
through, it's taken me nearly 20 minutes to do it.
I hope I've done it justice. Again, I would just
re kind of reinforce what I was saying. This is a
very much a beginners course or a a polishing
up course, if you like. But read pythons own
documentation, because it will give you a good
rundown of everything in regards to everything
we've gone through in this course actually,
because this is the last video about coding.
The next video, we'll actually be taking what
we've learned throughout the course and just
using it to write a short program. So thank you
very much for watching this video. I've enjoyed
putting it together. Hope you've enjoyed it. And
I'll see you in the next video. Thank you bye bye
so virtual environments today, they're an
important part of any project. So we're
open here on pythons own documentation on
Doc's that python.org/three/tutorial/v Envy,
which is shorthand for virtual environment.
Okay, so have a read of this in your own time. So
virtual environments, why
are they so important? Well,
when you're programming when you're a
freelancer, or software engineer or developer,
whatever the case may be, when you are throughout
your career working on different projects,
you will soon realize that these projects
can only function if they've got a whole
list of different dependencies installed. Okay,
they might be third party packages in there,
say a web framework called Django, you'd first
have to install Django, and then they say install
pillow or requests or Django rest framework, you
would have heard of these some of these anyway.
However, all of these third party packages will
have different versions, the reason they have
different versions because they are configured in
a certain way to work. alongside other packages,
such as Python, we've got python three point 10
installed, or three point 10.2 installed on this
project. Older projects might be using Python
2.7. For instance, in which case, the third
party packages that you're installing have to be
able to work with those different dependencies.
And this is where virtual environments come into
it. Because if you were to install all of the
dependencies globally, you will have a whole bunch
of conflicts. So project one will need Python 2.7,
and Django 1.8, for instance. And if you had all
of those installed globally on your machine, well,
you'd be in a spot of bother when trying to run
project B that requires Python, three point 10,
for instance. So this is where virtual
environments come in, you are able to create
this little environment on your machine, install
project dependencies within just that environment,
and fire that up and work with that
environment on your project. That way,
you can have one container for project one
using dependency A, B and C, you'll have
another project project B using dependency X, Y
and Zed. Okay, they are really, really helpful.
Now you can follow the walkthrough tutorial on
the page that I'm on here using Python or in
my case it'd be p y dash M, V and V and you
can create a virtual environment like that.
By all means, go ahead, it will create the virtual
environment in the path tree that we're in in the
video. to code however, I find using a third
party package called virtual EMV wrapper to be
a much better direction to go. So if you
visit this here, which is a zoom in, so
P ypi.org/project/virtual env V wrapper. So let's
have a look again, virtually in V Rapidash. When
that's the Windows version of this, what it does,
it allows us to install this package globally.
And then we can use commands such as, make
virtual environment, and then name it.
And it always saves and creates and configures
a virtual environment in the same destination.
Normally, users slash your name slash NV, and then
you'll have a whole bunch of environments very,
very easy to manage. Whereas when you use the
Python alternative, this virtual environment
is saved normally in the project that you're
working in, and I just find virtually in V
rapid to be much, much easier to work with. So
all you do is you copy that command. Because
we've installed Python globally, we have access
to pi pi, or sorry, Pip P IP, new terminal,
and all you need to do is pip install, probably
got that actually copied on my copy that there.
There we have it same requirements already
satisfied, because I have already got that
installed globally. So now what we do, we
will go and use a command, make virtual
envy. And we'll call this Python dash
course, when I press Enter, they'll
go ahead and install or create a
virtual environment on my machine.
In the folder, C drive uses Bobby slash e n v.
And then there'll be a folder in there called or
directory in there called Python dash course. And
within now we'll have a whole bunch of different
directory trees. And that's the environment.
So that's the new path that we'll be using and
installing project of installing packages into.
And the reason I know is working is because
I've got parentheses followed by the name of
the virtual envy. And now that is ready for
me to start installing things. So just
a bit about package manager called PIP,
they've got the pi pi library here. And you
can easily find packages by a simple Google.
Or you can go onto the main website.
And you can simply search here. So one,
normal, regular one that you'll see is pillow
that allows you to work with images in Python,
we've got recorded, this is one that we'll be
using in this in the next video sorry, requests
I want, which is a library that allows us to make
API calls. So in conjunction with other programs,
you've got another one is Django rest
framework. Oh, what have I done there.
There you go Django rest framework, a very, very
famous third party package that you can install
that allows you to use Django just which is a web
framework just as a API back end. And then you can
link the web framework with a front end
such as react, for instance, anyway,
that is P IP, that is a package manager, and we
install from there using P IP to the PIP command.
And that's actually install have already done
virtually in V wrapper. Let's go pip install
requests. See that just behind my head, there are
pip install requests that will go about an install
requests into that environment. I might as well
just open up the environment whilst we're here.
C Drive users, Bobby, in V invece. Well,
we got Python course Python course.
Lovely. Okay, so this is the environment
we've got fired up. If you go into lib
site packages, a lot of these
packages, can you see that very well.
That's probably a little bit easier, right? A lot
of these packages come straight out of the box,
right? So if I'd shown you this before installing
requests, it might look a little bit different,
but we've just installed requests, can you see
that going to requests and this is the requests
package, there's a load of pi files all working
together. All we need to do is now import request
as a module into our project and we have full
access to all of these files, all of the classes,
functions and everything else has gone on
as function funky in that package we have
access to if we install it into our project,
it has come up with a command here saying
you can upgrade PIP so we need to do is just
copy that part there. You see that? There we
go copy that whole part there. And that
will go ahead and it will ask They Pip.
And that's all you need to do. So that is virtual
environments. I hope I did it justice hope you
now understand why we actually use them. It's
just the way of containing all the dependencies
of your project in a nice little bubble on
your machine, a nice little directory tree,
so that you can access them willy nilly,
and that I can deactivate. The activate
that. So now I know the virtual environment is
no longer working. And I can say work on demo.
There is no virtual environment called demo, I
think there is called demo one. There you go.
So I've got another virtual environment in there
called demo one. So I can turn one off and turn
one on, turn one off, turn one on. And that's a
good way of just working on different projects.
So I won't drivel on any longer than I need to.
That's the end of this video. Thanks for watching.
Hope you've enjoyed it. Hope you found it useful.
And I'll see you in the next video where we're
designing and writing our very, very first program
in this course. Thanks for watching. Bye bye.
Guys, so we write in our first project today, with
everything we've learned throughout this course,
it's opened up VS code has opened up a project of
P why you won't find that in a GitHub repository,
because I want to be coding this myself. So
you can follow along with how I think and also
see how poor I am at typing. Okay, so you'll be
following along with this one hopefully won't be
too clunky. But the previous videos have been
all prepared beforehand. This one hasn't. So
hopefully you will see what I'm trying to do here.
So the project will consist of us writing an API,
which is an application programming interface.
So our program will be talking to somebody else's
program. In this case, it's the Chuck
Norris API. So we'll make a request,
and it will respond a joke. Can't be too bad,
right. So we will be using the requests library,
which is something we installed in
the last video into virtually envy,
that is a library specifically for this. So we
use requests to make get post PUT and DELETE
requests to API's and get the response. So that's
what we're going to do. So if I open a terminal,
if I go work on Python, course, that will fire
up the virtual environment, because I've got the
parentheses there. And if I now put PIP
freeze out list, everything is installed
in that virtual environment, you can see here
we've got requests, because we installed that
in the last video. So happy days this close
that down or minimize that we don't need it.
So if you watch the models, video modules
video, say, you will know that we can now import
requests, because it's in a virtual environment.
So it's in our extended directory, directory tree,
we will also import now we'll leave it as
requests. So I'm going to using classes, because
I want to show you a base class in a real world
and a derived class. So here's a base class to
make the request to make the call. And
I'll use the derived class to actually
build the request itself, and then maybe call
a function a solid method in a base class. So
that's what we'll try and do, we'll be using
an if statement maybe or a match statement,
we'll be writing or raising a type errors or
exceptions, and use an F string. So it'd be
basically using a lot of the stuff we've
learned not everything but so you'll be
able to see that I'm using certain things that I
know, from my Python skills and actually writing
a program with it. So without further ado,
let's jump straight into it. So this class,
we'll call this API call, nice and
simple. And we use a text literal to say,
base class to make a basic API call with requests.
Happy days. And then what we'll do is so
the method we'll use this will kind of be a
global method, that will be a eight. We can
use this across numerous API's. That's why
we're putting in a base base class. So this one
just needs to be a method that allows us to call
and will pass yourself. So a password the instance
of itself and what we need to have posted through
be the method to get post put
delete. So method, and also
the endpoint the API. So API, yes, got a
URL. Okay. So, first thing we want to do
is do a if statement, we'll do
an if statement. So if method.
method equals equals no method lower, so we don't
know if there's going to be uppercase or not.
equals equals get. And we'll do something. So
get we will make the request itself. So our dot
requests dot get more parser API URL. Okay, nice
and easy. Now we could use an else statement.
I'll use a raise exceptions later on this won't
be is something that you can use, you'd have to
change this if you're going to use this in your
own program, because we need to capture the post
the PERT the Delete methods also. So we're not
going to use an else or an if else or anything
like that, because to save time, but we will now
do a match on the response. So with requests,
you get a status that you can tap into a status
status code that you can use to check whether
or not the API call was a success or success is
200. Or two, I want to it depends on the API.
But we want to check to make sure that the status
code of the API response is 200. And if it is,
then we'll return and if not, we'll raise a
Type error. Okay, so match our dots status code.
There we go. And we'll have a case statement
for this. And that will be 200. We'll have a
little bar to I want is basically saying
or, and in which case, we want to return.
And we just this just return a
string. Now it will be our dot Jason.
And I think it comes back as text.
Obviously, this is all you can change this
as value. So this particular API
is it returns a response, Jason,
you can then get the text specific text for
this called value. Now, obviously, that's
not gonna be the same on every API. But let's
assume it is for this, this example. And then
we'll have another case statement, which catches
everything else. And we'll say res type error. But
we just say, API error, shall we. So it doesn't
come if it doesn't come back as 200, it would
just raise API error. Not the best description.
But you can imagine using you can use different
exceptions and different strings and what have
you. And it can just basically work through the
different exceptions. So this is the cool method
that we'll be using in our derived class. So in
upper class, and we'll call this Chuck Norris. And
we will be putting API call in them because this
is the base class for the derived class. We'll
have another text literal, it will say, this is
the Chuck Norris API doesn't really know for this
example, but you can add a description. Okay, so
we want to club because this is specific for Chuck
Norris, we can have a class variable called URL.
And what I'll do HTTP s, and this is API dot API
dot Chuck norris.io. That's not going to work.
I still IO slash jokes, slash
random. Call Westermarck cat, gory,
equals, okay. And then what we'll do, we'll
construct an API URL by using a placeholder, okay,
and I'll show you what that means in a second.
Categories, equals and we'll have we'll just have
animal and also they have one called dev as well,
they have more but we'll keep it as dev animal.
And then we will not going to add
that now we will have done doing it so
in it partially self as we normally do,
and we'll also pass through category
because this will allow us to instantiate the
class with animal or Dev, okay, so we'll have self
dot category equals cat that glory, there
we go. And then now you could have if not,
self dot category in categories 10 I will
write it cat self dot category sorry.
So this is if instance variable is not in class
variable categories, then we can then raise
TypeError. Cat, not
options. Animal Okay, so that's
just the typo that will be shown.
Now we'll have DEF, and we'll have this one called
Get or parser itself. So this is the get request
for the derived class, you can also have a post
request, PUT request. Well, it depends on what
you want to do and how you want to construct it.
But essentially, the first thing we want to do
here is we want to construct the API URL. So we
want to use an F string with placeholders. And
the first placeholder will be self dot URL,
because that is the class variable we've got here.
Okay. Second one, we want to pass through the
category that we're passing through. So self dot
category. Okay. And then what we can do is return
self dot cool. This is the base class function.
This one here, you see, we need to pass through
method API URL. So we will go these positional
arguments, we don't need to use keywords. So we
can put get, or you can even put get like that,
because we're actually using the lower method. And
then we'll have API URL, we don't need to use self
because this this is just a variable that we're
using within the function there or a method. And
is that coming through value? returned on Jason?
Yeah, no shit, don't just just return
the strings. And that'll be just string.
That looks like it could work. Okay, so I'm
gonna make, I'm gonna go ahead and test that.
Hopefully, that'll work. So let's go to terminal.
And what we'll do, we'll go work on Python.
Course, that will fire up the virtual
environment, I know that I've got
parentheses followed by the name of the
virtual environment. Now we'll fire up our
Python interpreter. So we can use the modules
import, so import projects, or project,
which is this file here. Okay, so we're importing
project into the Python interpreter. And now what
we can do is we can go to API call dot
doc. API call not found also be projects
dot API call, dot doc. There we go. So
that we use in the Dunder doc method,
Dad's just to print out the text literal.
Actually, what we'll do is import know from
from, it doesn't matter. It doesn't
matter. Okay, so we now have access
to these classes in our Python interpreter.
So now what we'll do, we will instantiate
Chuck Norris to a variable c. So he if
we go, project, Chuck Norris. And women,
we need to pass through a category. So if I
just put a he'll come through and say, Look,
category options, animal death, because we've got
the TypeError. If we were to put through animal,
we now got C. So I can say see, dots. Get our
call it get Yeah, there we go get and we'll
pass through. Actually, we don't need to pass
or anything was work. Happy Days, it works. So
we just call the get method, the get method
is constructed a URL, and then it's called the
self cool method from the base class pass, we get
the new URL, and then it's going around in Bali,
this match statement. So it's matched, we used
an if statement for the actual GET request,
we could use a match statement. And then we use
the match statement with a case statement to look
at the status code. If the status code matches all
of this, then we get the value keyword from the
JSON response. And then we just return it into the
Python interpreter. So what is that joke? Well,
we got they say curiosity killed the cat. This is
false. Chuck Norris killed the cat, every single
one of them again, and then you can do it again.
Oh, always coming back for the same or no, this is
the same one the first time and then it made
another call. So Chuck Norris once wrote a nine
foot grizzly bear for an automatic carwash instead
of taking a shower. Okay. Should we make one more?
Oh is the same one that keeps
coming up with the same one.
There we go. So that works. That is the project.
You can see. If we go back to the code here,
you could easily just create a new
class. We could call this NASA.
Yeah, we can make an API call to the NASA API. We
would just need to change the URL would change the
categories if that was indeed the case that there
wasn't categories of was a few different sorts of
categories. I know in a nicer API, they've got
different cameras, and what have you. So you
might just configure the class slightly different.
But what won't change or possibly won't change is
the cool method in here. And if it was to change
slightly, you could overwrite it or extend it in
derived class. Okay, so I'm really happy with
that that actually did work really, really well.
So that is the end of this course, we've written
our first project is an API call to the Chuck
Norris API works really well. We're using classes,
base classes, derived classes, match statements,
if statements, we're using strings, we're using
all sorts of stuff, we're using lists here,
you can even go one step further. And you can, you
can maybe do a random pick of all of the different
categories. So you always got a randomized
response rather than animal. So when you
instantiate it, you won't get similar jokes. But
hopefully, you can see now from this project that,
you know, the world is your oyster, just play.
You've spent the last few hours going through
this course, I've showed you the absolute basics,
what I think are the fundamentals of understanding
Python. Okay, take what you've learned, write
some programs, that is the best possible way
that you can learn how to code in Python. Also,
always reference back to this cheat sheet. I'll
say it again, you can clone this down from my
GitHub repository, this is your cheat sheet,
please, please, please use it in two years time,
or two months time, you might look back and go,
ah, what did I What was that about dictionaries?
What is that about? tuples? Why can't I do X,
Y and Zed? What the methods did that whatever the
case may be, you've got a cheat sheet to clone it
down. It's for you or made it for you. So like
I say, this is the last video. This is the end
of the course. I've thoroughly enjoyed putting
it together. I hope a truly hope that you've
enjoyed watching it. Please, please please get
in touch if you have any questions whatsoever.
Thank you very much for watching, and I will
see you in the next course. Thank you. Bye bye